Tschü tschü tschü tschü tschü baited
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, was auch immer.
Twitch hat eh noch nicht gecheckt, dass da stream on ist.
Doch.
Alpha HD ist schon am Start.
Gebaited, aber richtig gebaited.
Aber eigentlich nicht gebaited.
Weil ich mach jetzt nicht wieder aus oder so.
Das ist Absicht.
Kein Gebait.
Von irgendwas anderes.
Aber wie hieß denn nochmal diese...
Wie hieß denn dieser...
Das ist doch...
Wie hieß denn dieser Typ nochmal...
Den die alle in...
Ihre MW2 Montages reingemacht haben.
Den hier, oder?
Der war in allen MW2 Montages drinne.
Huge. Headbang.
Das war doch der...
Den haben sie alle in MW2 Montages reingemacht.
Ich erinnere mich schon.
Das war doch der...
Den haben sie alle in allen MW2 Montages reingemacht.
Ich erinnere mich noch.
Da gab es noch Videos von...
Von...
Wie hieß das?
Sandy Ravage gab es da.
Gibt es den noch?
Vor 11 Monaten.
Ey ich mein...
Immerhin.
Den scheint es noch...
Den gibt es ungefähr genau so viel wie es mich noch gibt.
Auf YouTube würde ich mal behaupten.
Auch nur noch sehr am Rande.
Ah ja.
Das größten Verhältnis ist nicht richtig.
Gut das ist das kleinste Problem jetzt.
Ja also Leute, ich wollte mir mal heute mit euch zusammen
eine Sache angucken, die ich mir schon lange anschauen wollte.
Und zwar das hier.
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich nichts, was den ganzen Stream dauert.
Weil ich glaube, dass das ziemlich einfach ist.
Und zwar das hier wollte ich mir mit euch mal angucken.
Und zwar...
Ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen.
Da hat irgendjemand
anstatt CSS das verwendet.
Und ich wusste auch schon, dass...
Ich wusste, dass es das gibt.
Ich weiß auch so ungefähr, was es macht.
Und ich weiß auch ungefähr, wofür es da ist.
Aber ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt.
Das war irgendwie...
Sass in 20 Minuten.
Oder sowas.
Und ich muss sagen, ich fand das nicht verkehrt.
Das hat mich überzeugt,
dass man sich das mal angucken muss.
Also soweit ich das verstanden habe,
ist das quasi CSS.
Mit ein bisschen zusätzlicher Syntax,
wo man mehr machen kann.
20 Minuten fürs Sass.
Wieso meinst du, es ist zu lang oder zu kurz?
Wahrscheinlich brauchen wir schon ein bisschen länger für.
Aber wahrscheinlich sind wir die Streamer heute beschäftigt,
sich das im Detail mal anzugucken.
Aber es ist mehr oder weniger...
Also wenn ich das verstanden habe,
wenn ich das richtig kapiert habe...
Wie gesagt, ich wusste schon vorher, dass es das gibt.
Aber ich hab es mir nie so genau angeschaut.
Es ist normale CSS-Syntax.
Nur, dass man
noch ein paar andere sinnvolle Sachen drin machen kann.
Zum Beispiel kann man
wohl irgendwie...
Na gut, Variablen gibt es jetzt in CSS auch.
Wir gucken uns einfach mal das Getting Started
jetzt an und probieren das ein bisschen aus.
Da kann ich mal wieder meine
Huge-Frontend-Skills zeigen.
Kann ich mein...
Wie sagt man heutzutage so schön?
Mein Frontend-Game upsteppen.
Painstrap.
Ähm...
Also wie gesagt, Variablen kannst du.
Du kannst irgendwie
die Elemente besser
ineinander schachteln.
Man kann die Sachen in unterschiedliche Files
aufteilen. Modules
habe ich keine Ahnung, was
es sein soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht so wild.
Man kann irgendwelche Sachen einmal schreiben
und dann eben mehrfach inkluden und solche Sachen.
Das sieht wirklich ganz
gut aus. Wie gesagt, das gibt es schon
lange. Es ist das erste Mal, wo ich das
gesehen habe, ist
als ich noch Ruby on Rails verwende.
Hat mal irgendjemand
von euch Ruby on Rails verwendet?
Das ist ja nicht mehr angesagt.
Das ist ja so was
von extrem.
Es gibt schon Rails 5 mittlerweile.
Warte.
Moment.
Da gibt es schon 5. Ich habe irgendwie das letzte,
was ich benutzt habe, war keine Ahnung, 3.8
oder irgendwie sowas. Das ist
ewig her. Rails release
3.8 oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber Moment, es gibt schon
Version 6. What the fuck.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das mal vor
Uhrzeiten verwendet.
Oder 3.2.
Kann auch sein.
Ja, das sieht eher aus.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich das verwendet habe, war Ruby
on Rails 3.2. Und das
kam wann raus? Gibt es da irgendwie ein Datum?
Warum macht man release notes
ohne Datum?
2012. Ja, das kommt ungefähr hin,
weil ich das zuletzt verwendet habe.
Discourse ist mit Ruby gemacht,
aber Discourse geht mir mega
auf den Sack. Discourse
wurde dann immer erstmal eine halbe Stunde Javascript
Zeug nachladen muss und nicht richtig scrollen kannst.
Warum sich
diese Plattform durchgesetzt hat, ist mir auch
ein absolutes Rätsel.
Slay.Teddy.
6 Monate. Danke für den Sub. Exquisite.
Serious Max.
Naja, also wirklich, ich bin da fast
Frontend angeht. Nicht so der allergroße Checker.
Ich glaube, das ist, also SAS
und SCSS ist das gleiche.
Das ist bloß ein anderer
Dialekt. Also SAS
ist quasi mit Einrückung
so ein bisschen wie
Jaml. SCSS ist
quasi, CSS mit
ein bisschen mehr dabei. Das ist aber alles das gleiche.
Und LESS ist quasi so eine alternative
Implementierung. Ich weiß, das
Bootstrap war früher mal in LESS.
So die ersten Bootstrap-Versionen
waren irgendwie mal in LESS.
Aber weiß nicht, ob
das überhaupt noch, ist das überhaupt noch angesagt?
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht mehr
gar nicht
mehr im Trend. Ich glaube, das ist
outdated oder so.
Bootstrap ist echt
nicht mehr gut. Okay.
Wie gesagt, Frontend-mäßig kenne ich mich nicht so
wahnsinnig gut aus. Also
die meisten Sachen, die ich bisher gemacht habe,
weil ich sag ja immer so ein bisschen
Frontend-Gedöns, kommt man nicht drum herum.
Die meisten Frontend-Sachen,
die ich in letzter Zeit gemacht habe, waren
Vue.js mit
Vue.tify, wenn irgendwas
Ansehnliches sein muss. Das da.
So und
Tailwind, da kann ich
den Hype gar nicht drum verstehen, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Vielleicht habe ich
auch einfach nur nicht
groß genug einen Kopf, um Tailwind zu kapieren.
Das kann auch sein.
Material ist overused. Ja, das ist
das, was mich an Vue.tify auch nervt.
Das Material UI
Look ist
das neue Bootstrap.
Material UI Design,
das ist das Android.
Das habt ihr alle schon gesehen. Also Material
Design ist
diese Geschichte. Das ist quasi das, wie es bei
Android aussieht. Das ist das neue Bootstrap.
Früher hatte jede Webseite Bootstrap
Look. Heute hat jede zweite Webseite
Material UI Look.
Das geht sogar
so weit, dass es ein
Material UI für Windows
Forms gibt, Alter.
Mega Paynes Champ.
So, aber
okay, Chat, ich sehe
ein paar von euch verwenden Tailwind. Also ich
erzähle euch jetzt mal, was ich
verstanden habe, was Tailwind ist.
Da
könnt ihr mir erzählen, warum man es verwenden
soll oder was ich...
wo mein Kopf zu
small dafür ist. Also,
was ich kapiert habe, ist,
dass im Prinzip Tailwind CSS
kein richtiges
CSS Framework ist in
Richtung Bootstrap, wo du quasi fertige
Module kriegst. So, also fertige,
fertige... Ne, Module ist das falsche
Wort. Wie heißt das im Browser?
Wo du fertige Komponenten kriegst. Das ist in
Tailwind nicht so. Na, in Bootstrap kriegst du
quasi einen fertigen
Button mit sich Geschichten. Du kriegst
einen fertigen, keine Ahnung,
Data Table mit sich Geschichten. So, das ist
in Tailwind nicht so, aber
Tailwind ist
quasi eine riesige Sammlung
aus Helperklassen,
mit denen ich mein Zeug
stylen kann. Also, anstatt
ich jetzt schreibe,
keine Ahnung, Überschrift,
H2,
und da mache ich dann eine eigene Klasse,
irgendwie Highlight und
Color Red, gibt es dann schon eine
fertige Klasse dafür, so für Zentrieren
und für
Umbruch und
für Grid und sonstige
Gedöns. Aber,
wo ist der Vorteil?
Das habe ich, das leucht mir nämlich nicht ein.
Wo ist der Vorteil davon,
wenn ich erstmal 500 Klassen
oder so lernen muss in Tailwind
und du dann
quasi
in der eigenen CSS-Sprache
lernen musst, um dein
HTML zu stylen, anstatt
selbst CSS zu schreiben?
Das kapiere ich nicht.
WTF, du streamst auch ja schon
3 Jahre oder so?
Bist du jetzt gerade von YouTube
rüber gekommen, oder wie?
Also, deswegen
verstehe ich den Sinn hinter Tailwind
nicht so ganz. Also,
wenn ich 500 Klassen
lernen muss, dass ich meinen HTML
stylen kann, dann kann ich doch auch einfach
CSS lernen oder Sass
oder sonst was und
meinen HTML stylen auf dem
Weg, wie das eigentlich vom Browser-Hersteller
gedacht ist. Vielleicht habe ich aber
auch die Genialität von
Tailwind nicht kapiert, aber so sieht es für
mich aus und ich verstehe den Sinn von Tailwind
einfach nicht. Den Sinn von Bootstrap,
den Sinn von
von Viewtify
und sonst was, das habe ich
kapiert, da kriegst du fertige Sachen,
also beispielsweise, auch wenn
es 0x15 Material Design
aussieht, aber bei Viewtify kannst du
sagen, aha, Components und dann sagst
dir Data Table und dann
hast du halt eine fix und fertige Data Table,
wo du sortieren kannst,
wo du suchen kannst, wo du
Paging machen kannst und was auch immer. Also
den Sinn davon verstehe ich,
man kann ja, man sieht es ja,
das ist halt fix und fertig, man kann es einfach wenden,
aber das ist ja in Tailwind nicht. Also wo ist der Sinn
von Tailwind, das verstehe ich nicht so genau.
Tainser sagt,
es geht halt schneller einfach, die Klassen
in HTML rein zu hauen, anstatt hier einen
Namen auszudenken, dann CSS
zu schreiben, dann wieder zu HTML zu packen.
Meinst du, das geht wirklich so viel schneller?
Also ja, am Anfang vielleicht,
also
wenn ich jetzt was zentrieren will, ich muss einfach
nur noch sagen, Class Center, okay,
aber ob ich jetzt einfach sage, Class Center
oder ob ich einmal in meine Styles
umgehe und sage,
Class Center und dann
an jedes Element ein Center dran,
ja gut, stimmt, man muss keine
CSS Files managen, dafür muss
dann 500 Texts auswendig lernen,
die sich ein anderer für dich ausgedacht hat, was
es vielleicht auch schwieriger macht. Vielleicht gucke ich
mir das irgendwann mal an, aber ich habe
den Sinn noch nicht so 100%
kapiert.
So, T
from the future
8 Monate, das ist ja kurz
vor
eigentlich schon für den Sub, Poggers.
Morgen kommt
der Telekom Netzingenieur.
Also Sebaro, ich will es jetzt ja nicht
beschwören, ja,
aber die haben dich
das letzte Mal auch schon versetzt.
Ich hoffe ja, dass
der kommt, ja.
Der soll mal anrücken
oder Zeug fixen.
Richtig PP-Gas, Alter.
Massive PP-Gas.
Gut, also so sieht es aus. Und jetzt nochmal zu dieser
Sache mit Discourse, das ist auch so eine Plattform,
die ich nicht genau kapiert habe. Zum Beispiel
der Spiegel oder so, die haben
auch Discourse. So, ich mache
mal x-beliebigen Spiegelartikel auf.
Was weiß ich,
irgendwie das da, aber wenn man jetzt runter scrollt,
ist das, glaub, Discourse bei denen auch.
Nee, okay, bei denen war es nicht Discourse
oder doch Discourse. Ach, ich weiß nicht,
oder was Eigenes.
Äh.
Warte mal, wer hat, wer hat einen Discourse?
Ich hab's voll vergessen, es gibt total oft
alle WordPress-Blocks haben Discourse
und sowas.
Discourse, Dis-, Dis-, ach, ich, nee,
Dis-, Dis-, krass.
Ich glaub, das meine ich.
Ich glaub, das meine ich. Oder mein, Moment,
oder meine ich, oder meine ich das?
Ich bin verwirrt. Warte mal.
Was ist das Kommentarsystem?
Mein ich das,
oder mein ich, mein ich das?
Äh.
Ich mein, das Kommentarsystem, ich glaub, ich mein das.
Oh. Und
ich find
das halt extrem, genau, das sind diese
Sorten von, ich find das halt extrem
nervig, dass das
quasi so
embedded ist auf der Seite. Und du kannst
da drin auch nicht richtig scrollen und solche
Geschichten. Das ist ja schon, das ist
ja schon was, was mir an Reddit immer übelst auf
den Keks geht. Geh da mal zum Beispiel,
ja, Self-Hosted-Reddit.
So. Ich, also, mal davon abgesehen,
dass ich ja, ehrlich gesagt,
eher, lieber Old,
Old-Reddit verwende, als
New-Reddit. Aber
wer ist denn auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen
mit endless scroll hier drauf?
Oder noch schlimmer?
Moment, noch schlimmer, pass mal auf.
Wir gehen jetzt mal auf ein YouTube-Video von
mir und wir sagen jetzt mal,
ah, ok, ich weiß, der Sebaro
hat da einen Kommentar geschrieben, irgendwie
vorgestern, ich guck mal nach.
Ich hab keine Chance das zu finden.
Es gibt keine Pages, es gibt keine
Suchmöglichkeiten, es gibt keine Pages. Ich
weiß, dass man theoretisch suchen kann in den
Kanal-Settings, aber das kann
ich machen. Wenn du dein eigenes Kommentar
suchst, oder ich unter einem anderen
Video jemand gesehen hab, und mir gedacht
hab ich Antwort gemacht, du findest das nicht. Du kannst
komplett verknicken, du kannst komplett, du findest
das nicht.
Warum gibt's hier endless scroll?
Nee, Steuerung F geht
nicht. Guck mal, du siehst ja, der lädt immer
dynamisch nach.
Der lädt immer dynamisch nach, also sprich,
wenn das Kommentar, was jemand geschrieben hat,
zwei Tage alt ist, dann ist es ja
gar nicht geladen, wenn die Steuerung F
total beknackt.
Also ich mein, man kann natürlich
alles laden und dann Steuerung F
drücken, aber
das geht,
das geht auch nicht,
weil
die richtigen Big Brain
Seiten, die zum Beispiel Discast
verwenden, die machen das so.
Ich hab ein gutes Beispiel,
das Home Assistant Forum
ist so ein Kandidat.
Das Home Assistant Forum
ist so ein Kandidat, was ich auch
in der Handhabung extrem
nervig und umständlich finde.
Zum Beispiel,
ich mein, es sieht
aus wie eine normale Seite, ne?
Ist es aber nicht. Ups, wenn man
hier runter scrollt,
sieht man, es wird dynamisch geladen
und wenn man jetzt hoch scrollt,
sieht man, es ist dynamisch unloaded.
Das heißt, ich kann die Seite gar nicht mehr ordentlich
durchsuchen. Ich kann hier oben hingehen
und irgendwo sagen,
search this topic.
Aber warum muss
ich ne Funktion, die im Browser
eingebaut ist, nachbauen?
Das ist total,
total
bescheuert einfach nur, ich versteh's
nicht.
Ja, genau, es ist das Smartphone
optimiert, aber auf dem Desktop geht's
mal auf dem Keks. Was ist das?
Ja, das versuche ich heute rauszukriegen,
also ob es was taugt.
Es ist wohl ne bessere,
nein, es ist keine bessere CSS-Variante.
Es ist ein, wie sagt man so schön,
ein super Set von CSS, also sprich,
du kannst
CSS schreiben, allerdings kannst
du ein bisschen mehr machen und der
übersetzt dir das dann in CSS. Das ist
wohl ziemlich simpel und relativ
beliebt. Ich hab letztens in dem Video gesehen
und es sah ziemlich pock aus, was der
gemacht hat.
Ja, und das ist
einfach Schrott, so diese
Forumssache hier.
Guck, das ist, das ist
ich mein,
auf dem Handy
kann ich's noch irgendwie nachvollziehen,
aber ich wette mit euch,
das Ding hat
also
646 Posts
hat das.
Würde man das
laden, wäre das bei
einem aktuellen Desktoprechner
überhaupt kein Problem. 600
solcher Posts zu laden ist wirklich easy
as fuck. Aber selbst wenn man das nicht
machen würde und man sagt,
ok, man macht Pages mit 100
Posts pro Seite, wäre ja
auch noch ok. Aber so finde ich
ist das, du kannst, das
dumme ist, dass es komplett, und das
mag ich einfach nicht, es hebelt die
Browserfunktion aus. Scrollen geht nicht
mehr, also sprich Browser scrollen ist
kaputt, Browser Search ist
kaputt, dann überschreibt
das auch noch
Standard Browser Shortcuts,
Ctrl F, normalerweise das
Ctrl F, hier ist Ctrl F das
und scrollen geht nicht, man muss dieses eingebaute
Scrollen verwenden, ich kann das überhaupt nicht ab.
So, deswegen
verwende ich auch
immer nur Old Reddit.
Old Reddit hat
auch so schöne Sachen wie Pages.
Ich meine, Old Reddit sieht auch wirklich
old aus,
aber Old
Reddit ist lustigerweise, obwohl es so
alt ist, sogar viel schneller.
Ja, ich glaube die meisten, die
öfters am Start sind, nutzen wirklich
Old Reddit. Ich meine, es ist jetzt
nicht, also es ist jetzt nicht
die Ausgeburt der Schönheit, Old Reddit.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
ich persönlich finde New Reddit jetzt auch
nicht wahnsinnig hübsch.
Außer dass die die Seite
nicht richtig verwenden. Ich weiß, man muss
auf, äh, man muss auf
Classic View schalten
oder so.
Ich meine, es sieht ein bisschen
neuer aus, bisschen schöner, aber so ne
riesen Unterschied ist es nicht, und man darf eins
nicht vergessen, pass mal auf, wenn man hier jetzt
in die, ups, Moment, äh,
ich muss erst mal auf Desktop View schalten.
Guckt euch mal an, wie viel
der lädt, das ist Old Reddit,
der lädt,
guckt mal, 931
Kilobyte
und 2,5 MB
Resources, lädt er bei Old Reddit.
Sondern das passt mal auf,
ratet mal, wie viel New Reddit
läuft. Ich hab letztens erst geguckt, was, also
das ist Old Reddit, und New Reddit würde man
sagen, was ist besser, neuer, schöner, optimierter.
Was meint er, wie viel New Reddit hat?
Ja, Sebaro 10 MB ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, um die 10 MB Resources
und irgendwie 3 MB Java Script
oder sowas, guck mal mal.
Also erstens ist es viel
langsamer, wie man sieht.
Äh, what the...
Ok, ähm, also das
lädt einfach mal 40 MB.
Was, der Chat
ist weg?
Oh, oh Stream ist
da, oder?
Ne,
ne, ne, meine Vorschau
ist nur broken.
Das ist alles, meine Vorschau
ist broken, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Äh, die Chat Anzeige funktioniert
auch noch.
Die Chat Anzeige ist da, die funktioniert.
Ich seh sie doch in meiner
Vorschau.
Die ist auch nicht verdeckt.
Ach, der Chat
blockiert die Anzeige. Ach, jetzt weiß ich,
was ihr meint. Ach so, äh, wartet mal,
ähm,
äh, Moment,
Moment, äh,
äh,
Hallo?
Moment,
kann man keine, ah jetzt,
seht ihr es jetzt?
Ja, guckt mal,
40 MB,
40 MB
new reddit,
und jetzt zum Vergleich
old reddit, äh, ups,
old reddit,
äh,
what? Alter,
Firefox, äh,
Chrome, was auch immer,
mach einfach mal. So, und jetzt
old reddit, ihr seht,
ich mein, es ist klar, das neue
reddit lädt ja auch irgendwelche Bilder
und so vor, wobei man sich halt echt
fragen muss, ne? Ich hab, ich hab mir
das, wir machen das einfach anders, ich kann
doch den hier unten einpletten, oder ich
kann einfach links einpletten, das geht auch.
Was ich halt sehr fragwürdig finde, an
a new reddit ist,
oder am neuen
reddit, guckt mal, ich hab, ich hab
hier letztens, ich hab mir das letztens mal,
ähm,
letztens mal in Ruhe angeschaut, da sind
Videovorschau dabei.
Wenn ihr hier durchguckt.
Hier, Dash, da sind Videovorschau
dabei, ich verstehe
den Sinn, ich verstehe den Sinn davon nicht, warum reddit
Videos vorlädt. Kann
man nicht einfach, nen thumb,
äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh
preview thumbnail anzeigen?
Wo siehst du
da 40 MB hier,
äh, 15 MB, 15 MB
transfered und, ach
Moment, warte mal,
kann das sein dass transfer das was übertragen ist und 14 mb das überpackende das entpackende
entpackt entpackte was ist der unterschied zwischen transfer und und resources transfer
resources developer tools aha excellent stackoverflow what is the difference between transfer and resources
ok ok ok ok aha also was kommt raus compress size of all resources ok dann dann habe ich das
falsch interpretiert dann sind das 14 mb ja aber das macht ja noch das macht ja das macht das
verhältnis ja noch schlechter es sind 14,6 transfer und old und old sind plus 968 kb das
ist 14 mal größer oder 15 mal größer was machen die denn da ja genug genug ausgekotzt über reddit
ich finde reddit immer noch eine super plattform aber new reddit ist echt so eine beleidigung ich
meine wozu muss man hier jetzt videos vorladen ok ich muss mir noch den classic view angucken
ob es da ob es da besser ist nach moment merkt merkt moment merkt er sich nicht ob man den komp
welchen view der merkt sich doch mal welchen view man an hatte ja die videos werden direkt
abgespielt ist auch eine sache die finde ich so schön moment merkt merkt er merkt er sich
nicht was man eingestellt das merkt er sich doch normalerweise ok wir ignorieren das jetzt
einfach mal aber nur wenn man eingeloggt ist ja das ist ja auch so ein ding das geht natürlich
technisch nur wenn man eingeloggt ist keine ahnung was reddit los ist wie dem aus sei wir
machen erstmal hier alles schön sauber und letzten mal zack weg wunderbar so da widmen wir uns mal
dem eigentlichen thema des streams und ich mache mal kurz visual studio code auf codra ne wir machen
mal wir machen mal einen neuen ordner haben noch irgendwo tmp lull ok tmp tmp lull besser
name ich habe keine ahnung mehr was es ist ich lasse es mal kurz da mk dir tmp so perfekt
beste deswegen finde ich auch meine eigenen projekte immer so gut weil ich diese toll benenne
beide mal es gibt eine lösung für jubel mit twitch ok sehr gut exzellent habe ich im chat
irgendwas übersehen kann man schauen es was es gibt jetzt twitch soundtrack für lizenzfreie
musik echt wo denn ich kenne mich ich kenne mich doch auf twitch nicht aus weißte noch aber ich
habe ich noch nicht gesehen ich habe da bestimmt ich habe da garantiert eine benachrichtigung
drüber bekommen ich glaube ich habe nichts übersehen nope sieht gut aus warum kein
aiya support weil ich kann fft moment was ist hier los
warum geht das nicht sekunde das muss man das muss man gleich gleich ändern das muss
man gleich das muss jetzt weg das muss man gleich ändern und zwar er uns
mein wo ist es denn ja bett und steve enabled gift emotes animated alles klar jetzt geht's
ich refresh mal refreshen und jetzt ist es nicht mal dark theme ok das wird jetzt mal
testen exzellent cute chat am werk
sehr gut was kannst du mal anschauen kann damit was passieren wenn man da was ändert
mal gucken ich glaube dass ich weiß nicht ob twitch das so gerne hat wenn man das im
stream bespricht ehrlich gesagt das ist eventuell eventuell ist so was sogar monka tos ich weiß
es gar nicht ich könnte mir nur vorstellen dass sie das nicht so geil finden also wenn
ich twitch wäre würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht so geil finden twitch broadcast soundtrack
melde dich für die lavate liste an lofi hip hop beats electronic rap ok das ist ja schon
mal nicht meins aber für den hintergrund sound ist es ok
das ist ein bild gbd ok naja wir widmen uns jetzt mal der eigentlichen sache was wir heute
machen wollen und zwar das da wollte ich mir angucken so und also was ich im vorfeld rüber
rausgekriegt habe ist erstens dass die seite kacke aussieht von denen das heißt was wir
jetzt erstmal machen muss es den dark reader anschalten damit man das jetzt überhaupt
ordentlich erkennt jetzt jetzt ist das schon ein bisschen erträglicher und ich war ich
war mal ein bisschen größer das ganze der zu lull reader genau übrigens habe ich hab
habe ich schon mal in letzter zeit erzählt wie geil meine heizungsüberwachung funktioniert
ich weiß das habe ich jeden stream erzählt aber ich bin immer noch begeistert wie gut
meine heizungsüberwachung funktioniert nur noch mal angemerkt nebenbei ich weiß ich hab
die letzten 50 streams gefühlt erzählt so also was ich jetzt was ich verstanden habe
davon was das ganze ist das ist quasi ein bisschen sowas wie templates in c++ nur nicht
ganz so schlimm also sprich man kann css schreiben mit ein bisschen mehr funktion und dann macht
es ein gültiges css daraus und man selbst muss halt weniger schreiben also man hat zum
beispiel variablen die er überall einsetzen kann man hat irgendwie so eine art kann so
eine art funktion machen die man die automatisch überall einsetzt man kann halt keine sachen
machen die css grundsätzlich nicht kann also wenn css zum beispiel keine sachen berechnen
kann dann kann sas auch dynamisch keine sachen berechnen also man kann mit sas nichts machen
wo der browser keinen support für hat was man allerdings machen kann ist man kann wohl
einfacher komplexes css schreiben ohne dass man fünf seiten css schreiben muss
also wir probieren das wir probieren es jetzt einfach mal aus das machen wir übrigens
nicht wir machen folgendes das habe ich das habe ich in einem video gesehen es gibt eine
original studio addon das nennt sich das war es nicht das hier live sas compiler damit
kann man sich den browser man sieht es hier da kann man sich den browser vorschauen machen
man tippt hier und der übersetzt das nebenbei im hintergrund und man kann auch automatisch
den browser refreshen lassen das ist eigentlich wirklich ganz nützlich der ist ein update
available ja ok wir wollen mal nicht so sein wir lassen ihn mal wischl studio code update
machen oh ich habe das offizielle richtig höchst offizielle wischl studio code installiert
erstmal paketquellen updaten nothing to update ok ich lasse ich lasse ihn einmal kurz wischl
studio neu installieren nicht dass wir irgendwelche bugs noch finden die in der neuen version
gefixt denn das geht ja relativ zackig der chat ist wieder an der grenze zu monka toss
ich sehe es schon
heute schon wieder stream so ja ich habe ich glaube ich habe fast eine woche am stück
oder so jetzt gestreamt wartet mal ne ne ne ne ne ne max ruhig ähm moment wo ihr schedule
guckt mal hier heute gestern vorgestern kann man da weiter zurück ne so ne kalender an
sich hat die javascript die javascript leute von twitch überfordert aber hier unter videos
kann man gucken hier guckt mal heute gestern vorgestern vorvorgestern zweimal zweimal sogar
äh ok ok ne hier waren mal hier waren mal drei tage stoppt dazwischen dann aber ich
hab doch ich hab ganz schön viel gestreamt in letzter tage guckt doch mal an hier 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 15 16 16 16 ne ich hab jetzt noch ein paar tippen und dann
16 16 ne ich kann nicht zählen warte mal es sind 5 äh 15 15 15 streams diesen monat schon
also quasi jeder zweite tag so also das ist für meine verhältnisse schon wirklich viel
so hat er jetzt geupdatet exzellent willst du sass oder css machen äh äh oder scss will
ich machen ich will scss machen ich kann also ich kann mal ganz kurz was zum unterschied
sagen sofern ich das äh richtig verstanden hab also man kann man also wir müssen jetzt
erstmal index html machen damit man was sieht index html und jetzt einen live server aufmachen
damit man was sieht so ahjaja also viel steht ja auf der seite noch nicht drauf sass test
so und jetzt können wir ein paar files anlegen also es gibt die möglichkeit dass man styles
punkt scss verwendet und dass man styles punkt sass verwendet so der unterschied ist jetzt
folgendes vielleicht haben wir hier so gerne mit unter auf der webseite vielleicht sogar
ein beispiel dafür das problem ist die webseite ist mit dem dark reader kaputt leute sonnenbrille
aufziehen difference sass sts also das eine ist mit einrückung das andere ist wie css
bloß ein bisschen mehr ist visual studio gratis ja ich weiß aber nicht ob du vielleicht
nicht eher visual studio code meinst also visual studio selber ist die community variante
gratis die normale also bei von der normalen visual studio das ist das normale visual studio
gibt es eine community variante die kostet nichts die standard professional kostet was
und visual studio code ist grundsätzlich kostenlos ja genau hier hat man schönes beispiel guckt
also scss ist einfach normales css mit also jedes gültige css ist gültiges scss an dem
moment das ist ein doofes beispiel hier ist ein gutes beispiel so allerdings ist nicht
jedes gültige css gültiges sass also sass das war der ursprüng war glaube ich die ursprüngliche
variante das kommt noch aus ruby zeiten aber da muss man diesen diesen mist hier mit einrückung
schreiben das ist aber wirklich paint champ ich glaube das verwendet ehrlich gesagt auch
gar keiner mehr so ach guck hier kann man sogar hier kann man sogar dazwischen umschalten
so siehts mit scss aus und so siehts mit sass aus es sieht jetzt erstmal praktischer aus
wenn du es mit mit sass machst weil du kannst dir semi kolons sparen du kannst dir klammer
sparen und was kannst du dir noch sparen ich glaube das wars aber dementsprechend ist es
ist es eher eine neue eigene sprache als ein extended css und es wird wahrscheinlich später
sogar noch ein bisschen komplizierter ja guck mal hier hier musste dann das als einrückung
machen und sowas also ganz ehrlich dann mache ich es lieber so dann ist es css aber ein
bisschen enhance des css also ich werde kein sass machen das ganze projekt nennt sich halt
sass aber ich mache scss und habt ihr denn mal frage falls es jemand von euch verwendet
habt ihr habt ihr projekte die sass verwenden oder eher scss so wir müssen noch glaube
ich das stylecheat einbinden dass das funktioniert link styles excellent so und jetzt und jetzt
und jetzt erstmal das das allerwichtigste was wir einbinden müssen to smart redwich
tv so copy image location image ah yes also die wichtigste sache haben wir schonmal erledigt
so jetzt kanns ja weitergehen exquisite ja ok wie fangen wir jetzt am besten an styles
scss so ich würd sagen wir gucken uns einfach mal die beispiele an du musst die css ein
stimmt du hast recht ja klar ja aber die hat er noch gar nicht generiert aber du hast
recht ich muss die css datei einbinden weil der browser selbst versteht kein scss der
scss versteht plus css so genau man muss hier unten noch das ne sass hä moment hab ich
das hab ich das vorhin gar nicht installiert hab ich nur hab ich nur rumgelabert ich glaube
ich hab nur rumgelabert hab das gar nicht installiert excellent so wie man das kennt
jetzt haben wir es hier watch stars alles klar kann man den kann man den kram hier auch
mal ordentlich zumachen so guck jetzt seht ihr jetzt hat das ding jetzt als erst datei
generiert jetzt hat das ding jetzt als erst datei generiert das heißt wir können jetzt
anfangen wir machen mal wir fangen mal easy an weil ihr wisst ja ich bin jetzt nicht
der allergroße größte frontend checker aber der chat der chat kennt sich aus also
mal nachbar da machen wir jetzt irgendwie so links oder so rein ich muss mal kurz auf
dem zweiten bildschirm was aufmachen dass ich ein bisschen abgucken kann wie das bei
der anderen seite genau jetzt kannst du hier einfach links rein machen so und jetzt sollte
sie sollte sich noch eigentlich refreshen oder also die links sind leer null aber irgendwie
home aber sieht das das sieht ja sieht ja schön aus wie 1995 jetzt home wifi ich will
ja demnächst für ein esp 32 so ein kleines admin frontend machen und irgendwie info oder
sowas irgendwie so reicht nach bitte in den body muss man nach achso ja ich finde ja interessant
dass das überhaupt funktioniert wahrscheinlich macht er das für das macht der browser schon
für ein vermute ich mal ich denke mal der browser macht es schon für ein der fix mein
schlechtes mein schlechtes hat im elm macht er macht er für mich ganz so gut und jetzt
und jetzt fangen wir mal an mit mit mit stylesorn als erstes machen wir hier mal naf und dann
gucken wir uns mal beispiele an so wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt wir machen gleich am
anfang einer margin bottom 50 pixel dass das bild dann nicht so rein was exquisite so und
jetzt gucken wir uns mal beispiele an was man alles so machen kann also man kann variablen
verwenden das geht mittlerweile geht das in css auch was ist jetzt der vorteil davon wenn
ich das variablen nehme anstatt sss anstatt css variablen wahrscheinlich kann ich die
in wahrscheinlich kann ich die dann ins das funktionen und so verwenden was mit normalen
css variablen nicht kann
desorption schreibt kann mir wer erklären warum der bettel net launcher innerhalb von
19 stunden fast 205 hits zu telemetrie bettel net aufbauen will ja klar der will wissen
was du machst warum du nicht spielst du sollst spielen und gefälligst loot boxen und und
microtransactions kauf und die versuchen rauszubekommen warum kaufst du keine ich glaube
wenn ich auf aliexpress wäre eine stunde lang da würde der schon 705 sachen zurückschicken
kanns ja plocken mal gucken ob das damit klar kommt ok also dann dann probieren wir das
jetzt mal also sprich wir können variablen verwenden das bedeutet ich könnte da jetzt
sowas machen wie sagen wir mal keine ahnung blu wie sinnvoll das ist sei mal dahingestellt
blu und dann machen wir irgendwie blu toll wobei nie komm wir machen machen ein bisschen
schöneren ein bisschen schöneren plauton irgendwie sowas da so exzellent mach color
chuck norris was ist color chuck norris das kenne ich nicht was ist color chuck norris
ist das irgendein dienst oder ist koffee purple geh mal weg ne ne ne behalte ich behalte das
andere so 128 128 240 exquisite color so muss das so muss das sein kannst in sass auch schleifen
bauen und generieren aber braucht man das in seinen man kann in sass schleifen generieren
ne oder also ja du kannst wahrscheinlich so so so ein bisschen wie wie pre processor
und dinger in c++ man also sprich eine schleife die dann quasi unter der haube einfach nur
möglichst viel css generiert das könnte ich mir vorstellen dass das geht aber zur laufzeit
kann er nicht sein weil zur laufzeit kann er css selber keine schleifen 69 68 420 perfekt
so ich lasse ich lasse das jetzt erst mal ok das heißt man kann jetzt variablen anlegen
so das heißt wenn ich war ja ok wir legen wir legen noch mal ein bisschen mehr variablen
also wir machen noch mal blu blu kann background background was ich was für ein background
nehmen 11111 so bg der ist so background wobei ich will ich will ich will ein light light
background haben light background ist jetzt ein bisschen angenehmer irgendwie wie sowas
das klingt gut so so was können wir sonst noch machen keine ahnung text text brauchen
wir auch immer text machen wir einfach irgendwas irgendwas helles und dann brauchen dann ist
egal mehr brauchen wir irgendwie wir können auch sowas wie wie warning oder oder sowas
machen da machen wir irgendetwas orangsch aber orangsch weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht
was schöne orangsturn ist so das reicht dann zum ausprobieren erst mal aus ja orange das
sieht eklig aus exzellent orange genauso muss das sein so und da kann ich jetzt was machen
mit kleinen tipp man kann durch klick auf den wert im color picker die formatierung
ändern von rgb zu hex ah oh exzellent der chat ist wie immer heute da reicht das schon
über der chat ist heute wieder hier on point aber was habe ich davon jetzt in meinem prinzip
die gleiche farbe aber es heißt ich kann hier oben das heißt ich kann hier oben so
jetzt machen super gut so das heißt ich kann jetzt schon mal bei meiner bei meiner nafbar
wie mache ich denn das jetzt kann ich jetzt kann ich jetzt einfach sowas sagen wie was
was ich background oder so so sie im background color was ist eigentlich der unterschied zwischen
background und background color wobei gibt es background überhaupt so und da jetzt bg
da sieht er scheiße aus aber ich brauche etwas graues oder sowas was ist das ist das
grau ok bisschen so ok besser also ich meine es sieht mega beschissen aus ja background
ist ein short mit mehreren attributen für welches projekt lernst du jetzt css einfach
um es zu können dass wo wir wieder bei dem eigentlichen bei der eigentlichen sache sind
die ich in jedem stream sage wo es immer darum geht so nach dem motto mit was fängt man
am besten an oder was oder was soll ich machen oder oder oder besser noch wie kann ich dafür
sorgen dass ich nach der ausbildung das machen kann was ich will einfach lernen wenn es euch
spaß macht also wenn euch was interessiert einfach lernen einfach big brain modus aktivieren
und sich das angucken weil man kann es immer mal gebrauchen man kann es immer mal gebrauchen
und nachdem man an frontend sachen eh nicht dran vorbeikommt color palettes ja ich ok
ok das das muss nicht schön sein ich mache mal ein bisschen kleiner so jetzt sagen wir
erstmal dass das ding noch padding oder so 20 so es ist ein bisschen größer das sieht
halt richtig richtig hängen geblieben aus ja ok exzellent so und jetzt habe ich gesehen
ein feature von von sass ist dass man jetzt hier drinne beispielsweise schreiben kann
ich möchte dass alle meine links das habe ich vorhin schon gesehen das mal gucken wo
das steht hier genau also normales normales css ist ja so was bitte für body margin padding
hinzu alles klar der chat der kennt sich da besser aus als ich jetzt exzellent so also
normalerweise in css muss man das ja so machen wenn ich quasi ein link element in der navigations
leiste stylen will dann muss ich sagen naf a was dazu spürt spürt näher ob man spürt
ist jetzt ist jetzt die andere frage was dazu führt dass man halt so ewig lange dinger
hat die nicht zusammengehören und mit sass kann man jetzt diese sachen inline schreiben
nestet das finde ich ist eigentlich ein sehr praktisches feature weil dann steht es nämlich
genau an der stelle wo es sein muss also im normalen css müsste ich jetzt so was hier
schreiben um das also wir können es ja mal mit normalen css machen dann würde ich jetzt
zum beispiel sagen so was wie color und das haben wir jetzt hier blue haben wir da oben
schon angelegt so color blue so und jetzt sind meine links so hässlich so hässlich
blau da können wir noch sagen text decoration ist es nun so und jetzt sieht das jetzt sieht
es zwar auch kacke aus aber nicht mal ganz so kacke so und das blau gefällt mir gar
nicht das blau das als blau soll ein bisschen dunkler so gut so dann ändern wir noch mal
die font size aber noch irgendwie wobei ne wir ändern nicht die font size wir sagen
font family aber monospace oder sowas monospace ok wirklich wirklich besser ok das sieht
doch das sieht jetzt ein ticken das sieht jetzt ein ticken besser aus so abstände und
so machen wir gleich so jetzt machen wir big brain abstände mal gucken ob ich das hinkriege
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob ich das gebacken kriege flexbox wie ging das flex display warte
mal da bin ich auch das krieg ob ich das gebacken kriege auch display flex und dann kann man
irgendwie sagen just justify contents space hier exploding brain da ich mir das gemerkt
habe so jetzt ist das schön verteilt wir können wir können ja sogar wir können es
sogar noch noch besser machen hier vor haus jetzt oh jetzt wirds advanced guckt euch das
mal an jetzt gibt es emojis für die einzelnen punkte wireless da kann ich euch da kann ich
euch antenna heißt das glaube ich da kann ich euch einen ultra geilen service für zeigen
für icons das machen wir danach ich mache jetzt erstmal emojis hin das keine all zu
gute idee ist weil wenn manche emojis bei dem font nicht unterstützt wird dann funktioniert
es am ende nicht ja sowas wie font awesome aber ich kann euch das nennt sich fontello
das das zeige ich euch nachher das habe ich jetzt schon ein paar mal benutzt das ist wirklich
richtig big brain weil wenn man wenn man image fonts verwenden will also zum beispiel keiner
so materialize icons oder font awesome also sprich wenn man image fonts verwenden will
zum beispiel hier die material design icons da gab es irgendwie so ein search search search
ding und wo ist die suche für material material icons da gab es also gute seite zum suchen
das da ist das das cc fonts icons was weiß ich was du meinst genau da kann man jetzt hier
zum beispiel suchen nach nach wireless oder so und dann findet man passende icons für
access point so aber damit man das verwenden kann muss man die schriftart inkluden und
die schriftart ist freut mich nicht 500 kilobyte oder sowas sind das creative commons icons
die meisten schon ich glaube die lizenz steht sogar wenn man glück hat dabei aber ehrlich
gesagt ich habe mir noch nie gedanken drum gemacht habe es einfach verwendet ich glaube
die lizenz steht da irgendwo dabei ja zumindest dass ich das hier verwenden kann ist die sache
entweder mache ich das als svg sonst was rein oder ich include diesen kompletten material
icons font bei mir link hier hast du hier sind noch mal alle also die icons kann man
auf jeden fall verwenden die sind ja startmäßig mit dabei ich weiß gar nicht wo man stylesheet
wo es das offiziell gibt hier so da müsste ich da müsste ich das hier einbinden und
wie ich dazu gekommen bin dass das keine gute idee ist folgendes wenn man das auf dem micro
controller macht ist der kram ein bisschen fett guck mal wenn ich probst wenn ich den
kram runter lade so diesen icon font dann ist der moment das ist nicht das richtige
das ist das richtige da hat erstmal gebaited what ok das ist das richtige font fall und
das ist einfach das ist ein bisschen groß wenn man nur fünf icons braucht so zumindest
es gibt bestimmt noch andere varianten aber ich habe eine ultra geilen service gefunden
von ich glaube von tello war das genau so und da kann man sich jetzt die icons raussuchen
ich zeige euch das nachher mal weil ich habe wie gesagt ich habe den letzten letzten paar
für die letzten paar embedded spiele spiele rein auch schon verwendet da kann man sich
jetzt die icons raussuchen die man die man hätte aus verschiedenen image fonts also
man muss nicht unbedingt immer den gleichen image font verwenden also sagen jetzt mal
ich will dieses icon haben dieses icon und und was ich firmen wir update icon so da kann
man die sich enden und dann generierte einen image font der nur diese drei icons enthält
und dementsprechend keine ahnung 800 byte groß ist oder oder kilobyte oder so das ist
das ist richtig gut genauso aber dauernd web font safe kann euch mal zeigen wie das dann
aussieht da sind dann verschiedene sachen drinne guckt mal allein schon gezippt ist
das hier nur da sind verschiedenste formate drin erst mal was zum entpacken installieren
kurz wo habe ich es denn so und da ist das zeug jetzt in verschiedensten formaten drinne
und unter anderem gibt es ne 8 kilobyte datei oder ne 14 kilobyte datei die hat das quasi
als embedded css drinne sprich man muss noch nicht mal ein extra woops ok warum auch immer
ist es nicht offenhaft man muss es noch nicht mal als als extra datei laden sondern kann
es quasi direkt im css embedden und man kann jetzt und kann die icons verwenden das ist
echt cool also man hat den man hat die auswahl oh mein wimm spektrum man hat die auswahl
kompletten image font oder nur die image image die man braucht aus dem font also das
ist eine super super geschichte probieren wir gleich mal aus aber ich mache erstmal
ein paar emojis hier rein dass das zumindest ein bisschen hübscher aussieht so was nehmen
wir für firmware für firmware nehmen wir einfach den computer icon oder so exzellent
so mein meine font config ist nicht so ganz on point würde ich sagen so logs dann haben
wir irgendwie mal so noteblock und habe ich noch nie verwendet also wenn ich das entpacken
würde würde wollen dann würde ich einfach so machen ich habe nicht mal anzippen installiert
was ist was ist und habe ich noch nie hab ich nicht ausprobiert kenne ich nicht also
ich würde jetzt einfach anzippen installieren und das ding anzippen was mein ich installiert
ah ist installiert so ich würde es jetzt einfach anzippen und zack ist es da aber ich
wollte ja gar nicht anzippen so logs nehmen wir mal hier so ein block so und für info
nehmen wir mal info gibt es da so information jawoll ah das kenne ich das ist das icon was
wir uns geklaut haben für das display so ok also kommen wir mal wieder zu sas jetzt haben
wir ja schon eine super erstklassige navigationsleiste hier oben besser besser geht es ja kaum so
also was kann man damit jetzt machen genau ein vorteil von sas wie gesagt ist laut diesem
was wir gerade gesehen haben dass man das inline schreiben kann also das hier wäre ja noch
vollkommen normal gültiges css bis auf diese variablen aber sobald wir das hier rein machen
nicht mehr so das ist das ist ein sas feature dass ich quasi die sachen an die stelle nested
schreiben kann wo ich sie brauche man sieht es hat sich nix geändert und unter der haube
wenn man da mal in die styles reingucken hat er genau das gleiche generiert was ich vorher
auch hatte was macht er denn hier was ist der unterschied zwischen sas und scss das
projekt heißt sas ist die für ein esp projekt ich will für mein esp noch eine noch eine
webseite machen ja deswegen habe ich jetzt diese diese punkt hier umgenommen aber das
gerade ist nur zum sas ausprobieren was möchte er denn hier ja genau also sas heißt das
projekt und die haben zwei formate die haben sas und scss scss ist quasi ein superset also
eine übermenge und wie heißt das auf deutsch keine ahnung von css also sprich du kannst
jedes gültige css ist gültiges scss nur dass du in scss noch mehr machen kannst sas ist
ein bisschen wie jammel mit einrückungen und gedöns also ich glaube die meisten verwenden
scss ich finde ich finde das sas ein bisschen umständlich so mich jetzt gesehen habe weil
ich wenn ich css schreibe dann bin ich im kopf bei css und ich bei jammel einrückungen
du kannst mal kannst mal verklagen wir haben noch hier noch einen vergleich offen warte
mal wir haben doch noch einen vergleich offen genau das habe ich mich ja vorher auch gefragt
oder hier auf der guck mal hier kann man so umstellen so sieht es als scss aus und so
sieht es als als sas aus also in scss ist halt ein typisches css mit klammern und und
simikolon und hier musste halt auf einrückung achten dementsprechend kannst du auch das
display nicht so schreiben sondern muss halt das display jammel style mäßig einrücken
also mir gefällt es ehrlich gesagt so auch besser so was will er denn hier von mir eigentlich
das sind irgendwelche browser prefix dinger braucht man das überhaupt im jahr 2020 noch
braucht man browser prefixes noch ich meine wenn man nicht gerade internet explorer 11
und alle firefox versionen braucht man doch eigentlich gar nicht mehr das das können
sie doch eh alle es gibt doch keinen modernen browser metadata das niemand kann denn es
nicht kann es macht einfach nur die seite größer kann man das ausschalten was sind
browser prefixe das da also das ist wenn spezielle features noch nicht in allen browsers
drin sind oder wenn ein browser was unterstützt was andere browser nicht unterstützen oder
wenn die was unterstützen was noch nicht standardisiert ist dann führen die das mit so einem jeweiligen
prefix ein also zum beispiel minus webkit äh minus mozilla moment nee was ist denn
der mozilla prefix webkit kann es ja nicht sein motz motz ok alles klar was ist der prefix
vom ee der hat so was wahrscheinlich gar nicht oder was ist der prefix von random prefix
e ms opera ist minus o ms aha alles klar ich sehe der chat ist wieder big brain big brain
ich unterwegs ok also das ist für safari das ach hier steht doch ms das ist für internet
explorer ja mozilla braucht das nicht einstelle für die extension live sass compile settings
auto prefix ah das ist gut das will ich nämlich rausschmeißen weil das das braucht mir einfach
nur zu viel speicher und ich gehe da eh nur mit modernen browser drauf kartoffel 1503
twitch prime ein neuer sub dankeschön huge massive big brain subscription so live sass
compiler wo steht da was von prefix moment ich suche einfach mal hier prefix ach hier
guck mal auto prefix ok was was kann ich was kann ich da einstelle 0 ich mach mal die hilfe
ich mach mal die hilfeseite auf die grad verlinkt hast weil ich will das ausschalten auto prefix
mit null zu turn off default ist null äh ne ne ne ne ne default ist nicht null default
macht er das ja gerade aber es ist immer noch drin
ach guck mal jetzt ist weg sehr sehr sehr nice ok wir haben es ausgeschaltet jetzt ist
der teil ein bisschen kleiner weil ich brauche keine browser prefix ich gehe da mit dem
neuesten chrome und dem neuesten firefox drauf und das war es vielleicht ja auch mit dem
opera gaming browser aber nicht nicht damit ist das nicht ein bisschen overkill weiß
ich nicht es interessiert mich einfach wo wir wieder beim thema sind wenn ein sachen
interessieren ist das beste man lernt die weil man kann sie garantiert mal irgendwann
brauchen und man rutscht auch so in bereiche rein wo man teilweise noch gar nicht wusste
dass da irgendwie äh was da so abgeht ach stimmt wenn ich es unleashed wollten sie
ja heute auch da muss ich mal kurz äh äh da muss ich mal kurz äh schauen das ist ja
dieser battlefield 3 mod der battlefield 3 wieder spielbar machen will das das das gucken
wir uns äh das gucken wir uns hier nach an das gucken wir uns hier das gucken wir uns
wenn wir fertig sind an so also jetzt machen wir erst mal jetzt mal erst mal sagt vielleicht
kann ich immer zig sachen gleichzeitig machen es hier ist max hat er merkt wie sein IQ steigt
ja deswegen habe ich das bild ja auch eingeblendet weil das wirkt sich natürlich auf mich auch
aus sonst kann ich das kann man einfacher lernen hast du bist den ganzen tag im work
mode exzellent oder eher nicht exzellent je nachdem ob es was gutes oder was schlechtes
ist so also was kann man jetzt sonst noch schönes mal ich meine das ist schon mal ganz
nett dass man so variable verwenden kann und dass man ähm die sachen inline schreiben
kann das ist ja ganz nice moin captain peng was kann man denn sonst noch schönes damit
machen variables haben wir gemacht nesting haben wir uns angeguckt was haben die noch
im beispiel drin stehen naja gut das ist ja im prinzip das was wir ausprobiert haben
oh herring angular 2 das ist so ein ding da habe ich ganz viel ganz viel ganz großen
bogen bisher drum gemacht habe ich auch absolut kein bock was was dran zu machen so was kommen
man parcels ok da kann man die sachen aufsplitten modules da habe ich den sinn noch nicht gecheckt
von mix ins da kann man quasi sachen inkluden also man kann quasi einmal sachen wenn ich
das so verstehe man kann einmal sachen schreiben und die dann an den passenden stellen inkluden
und man muss ihn noch einmal schreiben extent man kann sachen erweitern operate dass man
kann irgendwelche sachen berechnen lassen ich habe aber in dem video was ich habe mir
so ein 20 minuten oder sass in 20 minuten video angeschaut und der typ hat also wir
können ja mal werbung machen ich habe mir das das video angeschaut und daraufhin habe
ich gesagt das muss ich mir mal muss ich mir mal näher angucken dass da sass in 20 minuten
und er hat irgendein feature gezeigt dass man also was man ja gerne macht ist zum beispiel
ich sowas ja hava so also sprich wenn ich jetzt über den über den link drüber gehe
dann dann dann sage ich zum beispiel text text decoration hier anderlei oder sowas und wenn
ich da drüber gehe dann kommt halt so ein unter so so ein underscore strich so man konnte
das irgendwie abkürzen und ich habe keine ahnung mehr wie er das gemacht hat das war
poggers wie er das gemacht und ein und war das genau syrien der ist der kennt sich aus
hier und genau und hat das gemacht das ist jetzt bei einem a natürlich ein bisschen
doofes beispiel weil ein a ist halt auch nur ein buchstaben aber zum beispiel wenn man
sowas hier hat sieht sieht schon ist so natürlich besser als als so ich glaube hat button überhaupt
und hava was nicht das das finde ich eigentlich ganz praktisch das war das feature war sie
lustigerweise das feature was ich im video gesehen habe was wo was wo ich gesagt habe
ich muss mir das mal angucken muss aber in klammern vom a wat nee geht doch auch so
ane moment wat achso ich habe jetzt hava gemacht für die gesamte nachbar ups verstehe ja das
ist aber noch besser das ist aber noch besser weil dann steht es jetzt lokal beim a dabei
das heißt ich muss gar nichts mehr großartig suchen ich gucke mir mal das css an was der
jetzt unter der haube generiert hat genau also man sieht schon okay ehrlich gesagt an der
stelle sieht man das noch nicht dass man kürzer ist aber es ist auf jeden fall übersichtlicher
also ich finde das viel angenehmer wenn das hier in line drin steht bei der naf wenn man
wenn man sich vorstellt man hat den man hat den kram später hat man irgendwie hier keine
ahnung 50 50.000 verschiedene dinger drin so und jetzt muss ich naf naf link elemente
suchen so und dann finde ich hier war es dann finde ich da unten was und hier habe ich alles
bei der naf zusammen stehen das hat das hat dass es deutlich kürzer ist sieht man jetzt
noch nicht weil es noch so kurz also noch ist es noch noch sieht man den vorteil davon
ich aber ich glaube dass es später tatsächlich auch eine ganze ecke kürzer wird was man
gebastelt hier so als was kann man noch schönes machen ist auch deutlich angenehmer zu schreiben
ja finde ich auch also ich finde auch man findet es besser so und ich sage das jetzt
so nach fünf minuten wie gesagt ich habe das mit noch nie großartig angeguckt weil es
ist ja auch in wenn irgendwelche sachen programmiert es ist immer praktischer wenn das eben an
der stelle steht wo du suchst deswegen bin ich auch überhaupt kein fan von dass man
die sachen unnötig auf splittet also man muss keine metoden programmieren die irgendwie
fünf seiten lang sind ja das muss nicht sein aber ich finde es besser man schreibt es vielleicht
ein bisschen länger und dafür hat man die wichtigen sachen die für die logik relevant
sind an der stelle stehen wo sie verwendet werden als man macht noch mal fünf fünf
untermethoden irgendwie draus die nur an dieser einen stelle aufgerufen werden da muss man
wild hin und her springen ohne dass man was findet ich habe mal einen webcast geguckt
einen habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt ein ein konferenz talk von irgendem ruby guru
habe ich mir angeguckt und der hat erzählt dass er der meinung ist dass metoden die länger
als eine zeile sind für ihn schon schlecht ist da habe ich mir gedacht was ist mit dem
typos also besteht dem seine codebase quasi für in der hallo welt dann aus aus irgendwie
erst bei 800 800 funktionen oder was total hängen geblieben ja und ich habe das wie gesagt
so 2011 12 geguckt wo ich noch mit ruby on rails rum gewurstet habe und ich habe das
damals geglaubt ich habe gesagt man muss das alles möglichst kurz machen und das hat dazu
geführt dass man die sachen unnötig aufgesplittet hat also ich mache es immer so wenn man den
metoden also wenn man was extra hier in der eigenen metode dann immer erst wenn es entweder
gar zu extrem lang wird oder was aber eigentlich die viel bessere variante ist sobald man es
an mehr als einer stelle verwenden kann wenn man es nur an einer stelle braucht ist es
meistens am besten auch wenn es ein bisschen länger wird wenn man den kram an die stelle
schreibt wo er gehört weil es hat doch wirklich keiner was davon wenn ich irgendwie keine
ahnung ich habe eine metode die was die was einliest sortiert und dann irgendwo hinschreibt
was man machen kann ist dass man die auf splittet in input sort output ok auch wenn das nur
an einer stelle verwenden meinetwegen das leuchtet mir noch ein das ist klar strukturiert
und so das geht aber man muss nicht anfangen dort dann quasi sort first items third second
item oder sonst was raus zu splitten weil dann hat man das problem wenn irgendjemand
versucht den kram nachzuvollziehen der muss erst mal durch 2000 zeilen so aus kultur springen
bis er sich halbwegs zusammen gereimt hat was in deinem kopf vorgegangen ist als du
das gebastelt hast
captain peng exakt so ist es mehr als eine zeile ist er hat nicht gesagt plotet dieser
ruby typ hat gemeint it's a code smell ja
so weiter also das das finde ich schon alles sehr schick das das gefällt mir so also variable
maus für nestinger maus mit parcels parcels habe ich auch im video gesehen fand ich jetzt
persönlich nicht so ultra toll also was man machen kann ist folgendes wahrscheinlich bringt
es erst was wenn es größer wird also was man machen kann ist zum beispiel man kann
die teile in verschiedene dateien auslagern kann man es jetzt erst kompilieren lassen
vom webserver also das machst du normalerweise bevor du das auf den webserver deploys ich
meine ich will nicht ausschließen dass es nicht irgendwelche big brain node gs webserver
gibt die das machen können das wird mich hinter mich wundert nichts mehr im java script
ökosystem irgendwo aber eigentlich würde ich darauf tippen man macht das vorher bevor
man es auf den webserver schiebt so wie so wie irgendwelche webpack roll up bundle was
es da nicht alles gibt warum gibt es eigentlich für frontend sachen immer 30 konkurrierende
dinger das muss ja an sich nicht schlechtes sein aber die java script leute übertreiben
ist ein bisschen also ich muss sagen ich finde die webpack config ist abartig also das hat
das hat auch einer irgendwie so übelster menschenfeind sich ausgedacht die webpack config aber es
gibt irgendwie auch wieder also mir mir fallen schon aus dem stehgreif zwei alternativen
zu webpack ein und ich bin echt niemand dass ich frontend mäßig gut auskennt es gibt
da noch parcel und es gibt noch roll up genau und es gibt java script typisch 50 andere
dinger und das ist so ein ding was java script so ein eigenes java script ding es gibt zu
allem 50 wenn wenn es mal reicht 50 verschiedene sachen und alles ist irgendwie beliebt und
man man man steht dann davor und denkt sich so was de fuck was soll ich denn jetzt nehmen
das ist auch eine sache die finde ich an vue js ganz praktisch die haben die wichtigsten
sachen dabei das heißt dann ist nicht die frage welche von 1000 routing libraries soll
ich verwenden oder so oder nehme ich einfach den eingebauten und gut ist eine sache die
noch ähnlich wo auch jeder was eigenes bastelt ist ls ls replacements also ls hier ls replacements
ihr müsst mal auf github nach ls replacements suchen übrigens das ist das finde ich eigentlich
ganz gut hier es gibt bestimmt 150 ls replacements hsu zehn monate dankeschön für den sup exquisite
so machen wir mal weiter ich wollte jetzt ich wollte jetzt das mit mit mit parcels ausprobieren
was in der unterschied zwischen ach moment das geht nur mit mit das geht nur mit mit
darts ok dann müssen sie es gar nicht angucken da lobe ich mir doch jquery da gibt es wenigstens
nur eins wobei das stimmt gar nicht es gab es gab früher auch noch zepto oder wie das
hieß so als jquery alternative es gab es gab es gab zig dinger jquery war damals das
erste so 2000 frag mich nicht zwei oder so so also parcels also sprich man kann jetzt
zum beispiel diese variablen auslage in der eigene datei da bin ich mir unschlüssig wie
sinnvoll das ist also man kann jetzt folgendes machen mal angenommen ich hätte hier um 50
50 milliarden variablen gesetzt und das wird mir zu unübersichtlich dann könnte ich sagen
ok ich nehme alle meine variablen und mache eine eigene datei die ich keine ahnung war
punkt scss nenne da schreibe ich das jetzt rein und dann kann ich hier oben sagen include
use was include oder use use use und dann irgendwie war oder einfach nur war genau ihr seht
es hat sich nichts geändert kann man einfach nur war schreiben geht das auch exquisite
so jetzt kann ich quasi die variablen in kluden hier an der stelle hast du schon wo
man wo man ist absichtlich falsch geschrieben wo man als man ersatz da habe ich nicht und
ich bin ja auch ich bin ja auch ganz also ich verwende ja auch post man anstatt post woman
oder so wie das wie der ersatz hieß davon geht ja gar nicht aber das war einfach das
erste programm in dieser richtung was ich mir angeguckt habe das macht alles was ich
will so also sprich man kann den kram in kluden was glaube ich ganz nützlich ist wenn man
mehr hat also wenn ich jetzt ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen wenn ich ein bisschen
komplex der webseite habe dann habe ich da schon mal so was weiß ich 20 30 variablen
oder vielleicht auch 100 weil ich weiß keine ahnung so komplizierte dinge habe ich nicht
gemacht dann ist das ist das glaube ich ganz gut wenn man das auslagern kann wo es bestimmt
auch ganz nützlich ist wenn man verschiedene wenn man irgendwie verschiedene farbvariationen
ausprobieren will ja ich glaube das ist echt ganz praktisch mal angenommen ich möchte
jetzt global webseitenweit blau anders anders machen dann gehe ich immer variablen file
und sagt nee ich will lieber dieses blau und zack ist überall oder auch nicht ich muss
doch punktslash machen oder nicht import echt aber die schreiben hier use import ah hier
ja aber warum schreiben die hier use wenn man das mit import macht das für einen schwachsinn
but why also wenn die offizielle seite schon so mehrdeutig ist ist das nicht gut oder
ich verstehe nicht was die schreiben quai 1 neun monate auch wieder am start exquisite
subscription ok aber man hat gesehen es funktioniert also sprich wenn ich jetzt hier das blau wieder
zurück obs das blau wieder hallo wieder zurück enda auf das hellere blau dann wird es auch
wieder hell ach das ist use und und s css ist echt ok ja gut das ist ich nehme es mal
zur kenntnis dass das so ist aber ich finde es halt doof dass sie das hier nicht geschrieben
haben jetzt einfacher gewesen so ja das ist schon mal ganz nützlich so also was man jetzt
auch machen könnte es also bis jetzt mal total übertreiben ich könnte jetzt auch so was
hier machen new file knapp punkt s css und da würde ich jetzt quasi meine komplette
nav bar reinschieben und dann würde ich in meinem main css sagen import nav genau so
das ist wahrscheinlich sobald die seite ein bisschen größer wird ganz ganz sinnvoll
aber ich glaube das ist auch so ein feature was man nicht verwenden sollte einfach nur
um es zu verwenden sondern erst wenn es anfängt unübersichtlich zu werden zumindest ist das
zumindest ist das meine erfahrung so mit letzten jahren gewesen es gibt es gibt so ein paar
guidelines die die teilweise schon so fast so so so irgendwie religiös gefolgt werden
so nach dem motto du musst super jetzt müssen wir mal was einfallen du musst alle zum beispiel
sp.net kurse nach dem motto du musst alle deine models in einem model ordner schreiben
du musst alle deine controller jeweils einzeln in einem feil haben oder irgendwie ich glaube
bei controller geht es gar nicht anders wegen irgendwelche reflection geschichten oder du
musst deine db kontexte immer in eigener ding also ich bin der ansicht dass es alles schön
und gut aber man muss es für kleine projekte nicht übertreiben also man muss kleine projekte
die irgendwie nur 300 zeilen lang sind nicht aufsplitten in zehn feils nur weil das laut
hersteller best practice ist wenn es noch so klein und kurz und übersichtlich ist dass
es alles in einen feil passt finde ich spricht da überhaupt nichts dagegen das ist ja solche
empfehlungen die die davon herstellern kommen die sind ja auch im hinblick darauf dass das
empfehlungen sind die allgemein gültig haben allgemein gültig sein soll also sprich dass
wenn es der irgendwie eine super krasse business enterprise anwendung macht dann ist das natürlich
sinnvoll sowas zu machen deswegen ich denke man sollte die sachen eigentlich immer erst
dann machen wenn man selbst merkt dass es nervig wird also stellt man fest ok das zeug wird
mir jetzt zu lang zu unübersichtlich dann mache ich vielleicht eine extra klasse raus
ok das zeug wird mir jetzt zu lang zu unübersichtlich ok dann split ich vielleicht auf in ja was
gibt uns jetzt html oder es wird mir zu unübersichtlich dann mache ich vielleicht den db kontext aus
meinem start-up raus oder irgendwie sowas ja manche sachen sind allerdings tatsächlich
sinnvoll wenn man das macht weil bestimmte sachen sucht man halt an speziellen stellen
ja zum beispiel sucht man in einem asp.net projekt immer eine start-up punkt s h äh
man kann das anders konfigurieren aber das macht niemand und deswegen verwirrt es die
leute unglaublich und ein selbst wenn man sich das halbes jahr später wieder angucken
muss wenn man in in main irgendwie seinen start-up konfiguriert anstatt es da da punkt
s zu haben aber was ich damit sagen will ist einfach man muss die sachen nicht unbedingt
nur machen weil irgendwie einer gesagt hat in einem webcast oder so das ist super oder
weiter hersteller sagt das ist super ich ich handel es mittlerweile so dass ich viele sachen
so macht wie es mir am saubersten vorkommt und da ist halt vieles geschmackssache auf
der anderen seite wenn man sachen im team bastelt ja dann sollte man natürlich gucken
dass alle so ungefähr das gleiche machen also es hat zum beispiel keinen sinn wenn
irgendwie einer styles mit das macht und der andere mit scss das ist bescheuert wenn ihr
alleine da dran rumwurstet und euch gefällt das besser dann nimmt das und drauf geschissen
dass stss das verbreitete ist warum nicht ja ich müsste ich müsste mir da mal ein bisschen
mehr da gibt es da gibt es bestimmt viel bessere beispiele als die die mir jetzt gerade eingefallen
sind wo immer gesagt wird das muss das muss man so machen und das wäre total anti pet
anti pettern ist auch so ein komisch so geiles wort wenn man das so und so macht ich habe
ich habe schönes beispiel ich habe schönes beispiel es gibt in asp.net core was das nennt
sich so was man damit machen kann i hosted service ist im prinzip eine einfache variante
um um hintergrund sachen um sachen im hintergrund laufen zu lassen ich muss jetzt gar nicht
so sehr im detail eingehen was was sie da eigentlich genau machen aber es ist relativ
es ist relativ das ist wieder typisch ms beispiel dabei ist das übelst easy as fuck hallo
du machst eine klasse implementierst zwei metoden start stopp das war es mehr musst
du nicht machen so also zumindest wenn man nicht gerade so ein riesen fettes ms ms beispiel
ms beispiel basteln so und jetzt kommt ja irgendwann mal der fall dass man sagt ok also zum anwendungszweck
für so einen für so einen hintergrund service ist zum beispiel irgendwelche sachen die als
gelöscht markiert sind rauszuwerfen oder im hintergrund irgendwelche neuen sachen von
einer web api abzurufen oder sowas oder emails ja emails newsletter versenden was auch immer
also irgendwas was asynchron im hintergrund passieren muss so und da gibt es so eine regel
die sagt man sollte nicht und die schreiben halt nicht man sollte nicht sondern die schreiben
halt schon fast man darf nicht man sollte eben nicht aus diesen hintergrund diensten auf die
datenbank zugreifen was aber in vielen fällen gar nicht anders geht und ich habe am anfang auch
gedacht immer alter max kannst du das da nicht einfach aus dem hintergrund dienst auf die
datenbank zugreifen und das ist ja voll antipattern aber warum denn nicht man muss sich einfach nur
gedanken machen was man will weil die andere lösung wäre man müsste übelst kompliziertes
zeug basteln dann müsste irgendwelche vier fünf zusätzliche klassen in der dependency
injection registrieren dann müsste man gucken dass das eine in das andere injectet werden
kann nur dass man dann irgendwie also total total wir wenn man einfach nur den status in der
datenbank markieren will warum soll man das nicht aus dem hintergrund dienst machen letztendlich
muss es ja irgendwo gemacht werden und warum nicht an der stelle wo es anfällt die schreiben
halt bei ms so nach dem motto nein man sollte auf gar keinen fall auf die datenbank zugreifen aber
es geht halt nicht anders und bevor man da jetzt fünf neue klassen und 500 zeilen code basteln nur
dass man das an dieser einen stelle nicht machen muss macht man es halt einfach spricht überhaupt
nichts da es spricht wirklich gar nichts dagegen und ich habe mich früher viel zu sehr an solchen
offiziellen das macht man nicht gerichtet obwohl es an vielen von vielen stellen einfach tatsächlich
die einfachste lösung ist und die übersichtigste lösung so aber machen wir mal weiter was kann man
sonst auch schönes machen in sass modules gibt es nicht parcels haben ausprobiert mix ins ok jetzt
jetzt wirds big big brain time mix ins kommen wir machen wir machen erst noch mal unsere unsere
nav navigations leist irgendwie bei was kann man da können wir da irgendwie auch ich habe
eine idee wir können auch wir machen und border border border wie man konnte border in einem
schreiben 2 pixel solid und dann irgendwie black oder so ok das sieht mega kacke aus aber wir haben
noch eine variable gemacht für background background ist weiß moment background ist das gleiche wie
hier ne da kann ich mir das eigentlich sparen exzellent aber wir können sagen border radius
und da machen wir fünf pixel dann sieht es ein bisschen apple styliger auch abgerundet aus und
body machen wir mal padding zehn pixel dass man was sieht exquisite abgerundete ecken
so
na gut ich habe noch eine idee wir könnten auch eine sache mal probieren habe ich habe
ich roboto oder so installiert da machen wir mal von family moment habe ich das nicht woanders
schon stehen von family ach hier habe ich aber von family hier raus dann sieht es jetzt erst mal kurz
kacke aus roboto hier habe ich den installiert what apples what the fuck ok alles klar was ist
das für ein komisches preset apple system blink mac os ok wunderbar so lassen wir das perfekt
keine ahnung was es eigentlich jetzt was es alles macht kein java script framework bis jetzt das
wird keine website ich will mir einfach nur angucken wie es das funktioniert das wird
nichts fertig die animation ist kaputt leute brain brain explodiert aber ein browser ist
abgeschissen erzhaft wow der browser ist verreckt warum ist what the chat wer von euch ist das
ein in wer war es ja ja schon ok chat schon ok warum wird eigentlich dieses gift so schnell
abgespielt alle an alle anderen gifs vollkommen ok von der geschwindigkeit her aber dieses gif
hyper shit stimmt wir können das gift noch sentern was ist denn der neueste css big brain
wieg dieses gift zu sentern also ich würde jetzt sagen text center aber das ist bestimmt
nicht mehr best practice wie es so schön heißt also also man könnte man könnte jetzt ja sowas
hier machen text allein center aber das ist bestimmt nicht die justify content center aber
da muss ich sagen display flex was denn flex oder flex box was ist der unterschied zwischen
flex und flex box ist das gleich in ne kann er nicht sein flex macht das und flex box macht
das oder im moment gibt es flex box vielleicht in meinem browser nicht ach nee flex box gibt's
nicht aber um steht es dann hier drin visual studio ist gebadet ok so aber jetzt habe ich
ja alles so komisch gesendet was muss ich jetzt machen ich glaube ich muss mir mal ein flex box
tutorial angucken das funktioniert nicht der eierkopf muss in ein extra diff dann funktioniert das
nee hast du firefox ja habe ich was soll ich da sehen guide to flex box exquisite und auf
das diff dann die klasse setzten was welche klasse flex direction excellent ok jetzt ist
aber immer noch nicht in der mitte aber wahrscheinlich muss ich jetzt das diff wieder
weg machen ha ha exquisite ich finde es fast noch besser so das allein
nee aber vielleicht muss ich justify ich finde es noch viel besser ich lasse es so ich lasse
das so wahrscheinlich muss ich dem eine breite geben könnte das sein dass irgendwie sowas
aus nee was allein center fehlt was denn welches allein allein content allein was allein items
center ja aber dann ist sie nachbar auch in der mitte nur ok ich werde ich werde mal ich
muss mich mal mit mit der flex box geschichte beschäftigen in der zwischenzeit werde ich
mal folgendes machen auch wenn das auch wenn das absolut old school ist aber da weiß ich
dass es funktioniert ich lasse es jetzt erstmal so ich war ja ich weiß dass ich alles alleine
aber ich habe davon kein plastenschimmer gesagt ich bin nicht der ultra frontend kenner ich
lasse es jetzt erstmal so wir gucken wir wollten eigentlich das angucken und nicht how to
allein gif aber ist ja allein es ist jetzt es ist exquisite im center ok moment youtube
was flex box flex box in 15 minutes nee ich gucke mir das an weil von dem habe ich schon
das sas tutorial angeguckt das fand ich auch ganz gut das gucke ich mal zum einschlafen
auf dem tablet an und dann bin ich morgen ultra frei fährt und kann flex box easy aus
dem kopf auswendig einfach einfach pro tip einfach sachen vorm schlafen angucken dann
kann man sich das alles immer gut merken wann kommt css krit ich glaube sein flex box ist
krit total outdated ich weiß das dann morgen auch nicht aber ich finde trotzdem jetzt ohne
mist also ich finde ich finde wirklich dass es hilft wenn man also ich ich merke mir sachen
die ich mir vom form die ich mir zum einschlafen angucken besonders gut so also mix ins was
machen für mixins transform oh jetzt wird es aber exquisite big brain was machen die
dann hier
ich muss es jetzt mal ausprobieren ich habe also ich vermute mal ich vermute mal dass das
hier so eine art funktion ist die man die man quasi hier inkluden kann also sprich ich
kann die nicht ich muss sie nicht in box inkluden ich könnte zum beispiel auch in body inkluden
aber mal und alles mein body 30 prozent schape exzellent dann ist doch auch mal was ich finde
so sollte man das lassen so viel weil das geht ja schon fast als moderne kunst durch
ok ich glaube ich habe es kapiert ich glaube ich habe es halbwegs ich habe es halbwegs
gecheckt das heißt ich probiere ich probiere also man könnte quasi so was hier machen
so highlight und dann und dann sagen wir text text wird rot im highlight oder text wir haben
so eine variable für warning gemacht also sagen wir color ne mal mal fg ne moment
ne color color color ne gibt es nicht auch fg ne das gibt es nicht und foreground gibt
es auch nicht ok ist color und dann irgendwie warning
tja was machen wir dahinten als argument keine ahnung ich habe eine idee text bolt
bei gibt es das war aber noch mal war das hier text bolt wie macht man die text text
weight font weight font weight bolt exzellent ja bisschen undurchsichtig ist es manchmal
schon so und dann sagen wir so was hier wie genau size und wie war das jetzt dollar size
so also das heißt wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe ich mache das mal hier oben
drüber ich kann das jetzt an verschiedenen stellen verwenden also mal angenommen ich
möchte jetzt meine navigationsleiste oder hier von meinem link soll die schrift fett
und in bolt sein dann sage ich include include oh wir haben sogar auto complete highlight
oder sowas wie bolt ah yes ok kapiert ah stimmt wie sieht es mit default parameter aus
sowas sowas nee gibt sie fault parameter
default values passiv passiv default value for mixins oh man kann if else darin machen
what if else aber das kann man noch gar nicht dynamisch ok nee da könnte ich sowas sagen
wie wenn border size von dem jeweiligen element wo ich das mixin drauf anwende wenn das größer
als sowas ist dann möchte ich keine ahnung den den border durchsichtig machen wenn es
kleiner ist bin ich da irgendwie sowas es gibt auch bestimmt die fault arguments optional
arguments doppelpunkt was ist s css s css ist ein super set von css also sprich du kannst
alles machen was du in css machen kannst nur noch mehr doppelpunkt ist das ok ah es funktioniert
das ist praktisch das ist wirklich praktisch das ist echt praktisch also sprich wenn ich
jetzt was übergebe kann ich jetzt die klammern weglassen ach noch besser also sprich ok
ich meine in dem einen fall ist jetzt natürlich überflüssig da könnte ich das ja auch reinschreiben
aber man muss ja davon ausgehen dass man das auf mehrere dass man das auf mehrere objekte
anwenden will na also mal angenommen ich hätte irgendwie noch ups mal angenommen ich hätte
noch irgendwie einen button oder so weißt du um teufel wischel zu dir was machst du
denn da also mal angenommen ich hätte noch einen button und ich hätte dann irgendwie
noch was irgendwie noch anderes zeug da könnte ich dann auch hier sagen include highlight
und er würde er würde die sachen bolt und in warning color machen das ist echt praktisch
benötigt man für workstation pro 16 einen neuen key wenn man ein 15 ja immer aber ich
glaube es gibt relativ günstige upgrades ok das ist das ist echt das ist echt nützlich
das finde ich gut so wie sieht das mit if else aus das muss ich mir jetzt nochmal angucken
function sonst was ok es wird noch deutlich big brain brainiger was man machen kann
man kann man es gibt schleifen ok aber das ist ok das ist ja ein pre processor das heißt
man darf sich nicht jetzt irgendwie denken man könnte dort dynamisch irgendwelche sachen
machen während der user resized im browser das kann ja nicht funktionieren wenn es wenn
es pre pre process calculated ist also sprich diese sachen laufen nicht zur runtime also
wenn ich jetzt meinen browser resize kriegt da s css absolut nix von mit das heißt es
ist auch nur beschränkt nützlich ich war man könnte damit vielleicht verschiedene
klassen vor vor generieren also mal angenommen man möchte jetzt irgendwie eine tabelle oder
irgendwie den krit mit bis zu 20 elementen und man generiert sich quasi für jedes element
irgendwie einen passenden style vor oder sowas ja aber ich glaube das ist ich glaube nicht
dass man das so oft verwendet glaube ich glaube nicht dass man das so oft verwendet
wenn du was dynamisches brauchst css custom prob was sind css custom properties erst einmal
ich bin überhaupt nicht auf dem also die wahre css variablen sehr die kenne ich die
kenne ich wusste nicht dass die custom properties heißen ich dachte immer css variablen für
ja die kenne ich kenne ich so also das ist ja schon mal an sich ganz nice was was kann
man da sonst noch jetzt schönes machen es gab da noch die möglichkeit das zeug irgendwie
zu erweitern irgendwas mit extent gab es dann noch extent
was für was ist das prozentzeichen da vorne dran also mein extent was macht prozent was
macht ein prozent in css ich kenne punkt ich kenne raute ich kenne einfach nur element
aber was macht denn was macht denn achso das ist eine sassgeschichte placeholder selektor
achso jetzt verstehe ich also sprich diese sache landet nicht im css es sei denn ich
stände sie das ist quasi so eine base class um es war so ganz abstrakt zu sagen oder abstrueck
base class sogar noch besser das ist quasi irgend so ein ding von dem ich von dem ich
extenten kann die aber alleine nichts macht also sprich die taucht nie im css feil auf
sondern es taucht nur message im css feil auf das ist doch dann aber quasi ein bisschen
so was wie ein mixin oder große unterschied dazwischen ist jetzt ja nicht mixin hat parameter
ja richtig aber ich meine ich könnte ja einfach auch den mixin ohne parameter verwenden oder
ok ich glaube das ist so ein feature man weiß wenn man es braucht und dann kann man es verwenden
also man steht irgendwann mal vor einem problem und denkt sich ach da wäre das für ganz gut
dann verwendet man es wählt es da grad nichts zu ein aber das mit extent können wir noch
mal ausprobieren also sprich mal angenommen ich komme jetzt auf die glorreiche idee und
finde meine navigations bar so geil dass ich die extenten will da könnte ich dann so was
hier machen kann sup naf extent naf ne noch oder so und jetzt und jetzt könnte ich quasi
noch mal eine naf bar machen als diff und dann sagen class sup naf ohohoho magic ich
habe meine naf leiste geklont exquisite so und da könnte ich jetzt auch noch was ändern
drinnen und ich könnte zum beispiel sagen ja ne aber hier will ich jetzt color wieder
black haben ne das funktioniert nicht ach moment das ist ja auch in dem art drinne das
muss ich hier machen ach ne ich überschreibe das ja hier ne das ok das funktioniert nicht
das funktioniert nicht wie ich mir das gedacht habe aber prinzipiell also was ich zum beispiel
machen könnte ist sowas wie hier will ich jetzt border border color black so und dann
die momentan machen wir border 2 pixels solid black so geht das na genau und jetzt ist nur
die jetzt hat nur die einen rand und schwarz aber erbt alles andere also sprich das hover
erbt die von hier oben und so ok das das stelle ich mir auch äußerst praktisch vor
wenn man zum beispiel irgendwelche forms formelemente hat oder so die hat man ja vielleicht
auch in drei vier verschiedene formularen und man möchte mehr oder weniger immer das
gleiche stylen bis auf ein paar kleinigkeiten unterschied das das klingt das klingt eigentlich
ganz sinnvoll ja ja ich probiere jetzt konnte man nicht konnte man nicht color überschreiben
mit sache red und jetzt irgendwie important beim nee ach nee das geht nicht das geht nicht
das geht nicht weil das in dem art drunter ist ja aber schon mal nicht übel exquisite
im großen und ganzen jetzt mal so an die sas kenner im großen und ganzen war es das glaube
ich halbwegs oder also ich meine klar im detail gibt es da noch deutlich mehr also ich habe
jetzt gesehen man kann schleifen machen und und nur irgendwie fangt schon sachen auf aber
so im von den funktionsbereichen her war es das im großen und ganzen das ist eigentlich
ziemlich easy
ja man kann natürlich noch 30.000 andere sachen machen aber so von den funktionsbereichen
her habe ich den eindruck ist das ziemlich übersichtlich das finde ich gut ich glaube
das werde ich mal bei der nächsten sachen verwenden wir werden in einem der nächsten
streams das dashboard bauen für den esp 32 für nehme ich genau das wlan einstellung
firmware update und locks angucken weil aktuell geht das nur über karl befehle was vielleicht
jetzt nicht jedermanns geschmack ist letztendlich für mich kein problem also ich mache es lieber
über den karl befehl und letztendlich ist es eigentlich rausgeschmissene zeit insofern
weil ich eh der einzige bin der die sachen hier bei mir daheim verwendet aber ich glaube
ich finde es auch ich würde es auch ganz angenehm verwenden ganz angenehm finden wenn
ich zumindest verwenden könnte um wifi settings zu zu ändern übers web interface ich habe
es ja aktuell so gebaut auf dem esp 32 dass der zwei verschiedene oder bis zu drei verschiedene
wlan durchprobiert der probiert default wlan aus was er direkt eingestellt hat und guckt
bis in bis bis zu in zwei json dateien auf dem flash nach ob der weitere wifi settings
findet
wie es ganz schöne dashboards brennen ja aber ich glaube ich mache das dashboard nicht nicht
in die chairs weil ich habe nicht so viel flasche und ich will da wirklich alles möglich
sparen ich wollte mir das hier mal angucken weil da wohl relativ kleine falls rauskommen
oder im zweifelsfall einfach die sachen von hand ja was krippen braucht ja nicht so viel
wie groß wie groß ist der view js min und das ganze geht zippt zeigt mal her muss mal
gucken vielleicht vielleicht ist meine bedenken da auch unsinnig ist das die minifight variante
guck mal wie groß das ist so 91 k geht zippt oder mal ich muss ich ich blende das mal kurz
um so es ist auf jeden fall die minifight variante geht zippt das ganze wie groß 33k naja gut das
geht eigentlich noch aber auf der anderen seite sind es 33k umsonst die die ganze webseite ist
vielleicht 5k oder so ist aber also die sassgeschichte gefällt mir ich mag egen ich mag
eh allgemein so dinger die man innerhalb von paar stunden den überblick hat und halbwegs weiß was
sie was sie machen also nicht so was wie z++ zum beispiel oder gar cobalt also ich weiß ja dass
ich an weihnachten ein bisschen cobalt programmieren muss ja das hat mich dann der chat dazu schon
überredet und ich ich predikte jetzt schon mal eine sache cobalt werde ich wahnsinnig eklig und
oldschool finden aber ich finde es wahrscheinlich trotzdem besser als z++ weil weil einfach fast
also es gibt eigentlich kaum was was schlechter ist insofern wahrscheinlich sogar cobalt gefällt
mir noch besser als z++ es wird echt mal zeit dass man sp 2 nacht 32 und 86 sinnvoll in was
andere programmieren kann es gibt schon zig projekte aber wirklich sinnvoll ist es nur möglich in
c++ leider jo ja chat das ging schneller als gedacht rast embed ja es gibt schon ein paar
versuche dafür es gibt auch schon so experimentelle sachen für sp 32 aber das ist halt weit davon
entfernt dass sie wirklich wirklich gut benutzbar ist und ich muss halt sagen rast ist auch so ein
ding das ist schon so ein bisschen big brain ja aber guck mal der browser hat wieder den
löffel abgegeben rast ist teilweise aber auch nicht schön zu lesen also rast hat schon ein
bisschen also rast ist anders anders merkwürdig als z++ z++ ist merkwürdig weil es an vielen
stellen einfach total inkonsistent ist und man das gefühl hat das cremium will ein verarschen so
und bei rast ist es so man denkt permanent man ist zu dumm für ich glaube ich glaube das habe
ich ganz gut beschrieben ok ich habe das jetzt mal zugemacht warum auch immer das jetzt gecrasht
ist bei rast denkt man permanent man ist zu dumm für und bei css bei z++ denkt man permanent das
cremium will ein verarschen und ich finde die rast sonntags jetzt auch nicht die schönste die
besteht die besteht mir aus ein bisschen viel spitzen klammern denkst du dir irgendwann nochmal
was für channel points aus ja das mache ich dann wenn ich mir auch neue emotes hole aber spaß
beiseite ich habe wirklich vor nachdem ich jetzt ja auch gerade wieder viel streamen und ich weiß
recht und öfters gar ich will mir wirklich jetzt channel points besorgen nicht channel points
ordentlich emotes besorgen wir haben ja schon eine riesenliste gemacht mit emotes ich habe
ja glaube ich noch 25 emotes frei oder so massig ja ja go finde ich auch ganz ok die haben aber
auch ein paar merkwürdige entscheidungen aber ich habe schon eine weile nichts mein go gemacht dass
ich mich jetzt ich kann mich jetzt nicht so sehr drüber zum beispiel die sache dass es keine
generics wollten und jetzt doch irgendwie wie man sowas nicht wollen kann ist mir auch unbegreiflich
genau das gibt es nachdem ich mit dem youtube video fertig bin ne aber emotes ich habe wirklich
also die die wie soll ich sagen sie wirklich die absicht emotes zu machen jetzt peißen im stream
wäre nice ich bin kein großer peißen nicht fern kenne aber ich habe letztens was gemacht
da drin und es war sehr angenehm muss ich sagen ich sollte auf der arbeit jetzt ist
ihn auf letzten drücker wieder eingefallen ich sollte also es kam es kam es kam immer zu mir
und hat gefragt ob ich die dhcp konfig geht peißen auf dem esp 32 theoretisch schon aber
mit einschränkungen also es gibt micro peißen das geht ganz gut aber du hast du hast ein paar
einschränkungen die du mit c++ nicht hast zum beispiel wenn du den ssl webserver laufen lassen
willst oder so hast du nicht genug ram das geht mit c++ geht zum beispiel zumindest da sind
auf der arbeit zu mir kommen das wird auf letzten drücker eingefallen haben sie mich gefragt okay
ob ich ihnen nicht irgendwie eine linux dhcp server hinstellen könnte mit der konfig vom
windows dhcp server habe erst mal das kannst du vergessen im windows dhcp server stehen 30
milliarden sachen die du wahrscheinlich mit so einem ics gar nicht abbilden kannst so und irgendwann
haben sie dann gesagt ja okay verstehen wir es würde ihnen einfach reichen wenn man die zonen
und die reservierung umzieht und am ende haben sogar noch gesagt die reservierung braucht man
gar nicht einfach einfach alle dns ranges so und da habe ich so ein mini python script gebastelt
keine ahnung 30 zeilen oder so was des den windows dhcp export um konvertiert hat in
dhcp linux dhcp server konfig und ich muss sagen das war echt angenehm das in peißen zu
machen weil die haben alles mögliche dabei die haben sogar einen ip calculator dabei also kannst
sogar du kannst die haben in der standard library den ip calculator bei wo du quasi
p-adressen sachen dazu rechnen kannst ihn abziehen kannst weil bei der gelegenheit ist mir natürlich
aufgefallen weil sonst guckt da keiner drauf dass die ranges im windows dhcp falsch angelegt
waren die haben die ranges inklusive gateway angelegt normalerweise müssen so eine range
anlesen anlegen nach dem gateway dass das funktioniert liegt einfach daran dass der
dns vorher checkt ob die ip doppelt vergeben ist aber ich wollte keine konfig bauen die quasi
in sich schon falsch ist so und deswegen habe ich einfach die range genommen das netz angegeben
und mit diesem eingebauten ip modul die ip 1 hochgezählt weil ich wusste ok range start
ist immer der gateway und range start plus eins ist die erste dhcp range und das war
halt echt praktisch meine haben ein ip address calculator eingebaut die haben einen csv reader
eingebaut der windows export war übrigens csv weil ich weiß nicht was im jahr 2020 alle noch mit
csv haben gut ich meine es könnte noch schlimmer kommen es könnte auch xml sein aber mal ganz
ehrlich csv ist schon ist schon es dicht gefolgt auf xml also wer hat kein csv reader also mir
fallen jetzt wenige atmosphere fällt jetzt aus spontan keine programmier sprache ein die in
der die in ihrer standard library einen csv reader dabei hat dort net hat kein csv dabei ruby hat
standardmäßig glaube kein csv dabei go hat standardmäßig kein csv dabei sehr gut zählen
von 10 plus reden wir schon mal gar nicht hat stande mich kein kein dabei so sachen wie bash
natürlich ähnlich note also ja was gibt auch nicht also mir fällt außer heißt keine sprache
ein die standardmäßig einen csv reader dabei hat bei ruby bin ich mir nicht sicher
ok ruby hat ein dabei ok ruby hatten ein csv reader dabei alles klar
was go hat echt ein nades glaube ich nicht go hat auch standardmäßig kein csv reader dabei
ernsthaft wirklich
ne package ist das jetzt das ist auch so ein ding was mich an den go documents
nervt ist das jetzt standard library oder ist es irgendwas custom das ist nicht schlecht
na gut dort net hat zumindest keinen das weiß ich da musste ich mit irgendwelchen komischen
dingern rumschlagen die nicht gut funktionieren so note also note hat höchstwahrscheinlich auch
kein weil note standardmäßig sehr wenig dabei hat ja auch kein ja gut ist jetzt auch egal zumindest
ich fand es gut dass die sowohl in alpea trust calculator dabei haben als auch in den csv
reader das war wirklich praktisch kannst du dir im stream mal alternative datenbank system
anschauen ja aber ich weiß ich ob also ja ich wollte mir immer ein bisschen mehr sachen angucken
datenbank technische nächsterzeit aber ich weiß nicht ob das so interessant ist im stream weil
ich muss dir ehrlich sagen ich bin schon so ein bisschen datenbank noch auch teilweise was das
angeht weil ich verwende zu 95 prozent sq light so und ab und zu mal so was wie reddis das war es
also ich glaube ich habe ich überleg gerade habe ich schon mal für mein zeug was anderes verwendet
also wenn ich eine richtige datenbank bräuchte will ich postkurs verwenden aber
also ich habe gut ich meine du kannst ja mehr oder weniger das sql von sq lite auf postkurs
das kannst ja kannst ja verwenden aber ich glaube ich habe für mein zeug noch nie was
anderes außer reddis und also reddis und und sq lite verwendet a craft ql craft ql habe ich
auch schon verwendet aber das ist das zählt ja nicht nicht so wirklich als daten das ist
eher so ein aufsatz oft doch doch ich habe schon mal postkurs mit craft ql verwendet korrekt
stimmt da gibt es nämlich ein plugin was die datenbank per craft ql zugreifbar macht das habe
ich für unser routing routing planungsding verwendet ja ja doch genau stimmt da habe
ich aber ich habe noch nie wirklich von meinem zeug was ich hier daheim zusammen gewusstet
habe zumindest noch nie richtig echte datenbank verwendet brauche ich auch meistens nicht bei
den eins zwei drei maximal fünf usern oder so aber aber craft ql ist wirklich sehr nice so
ein alex drei monate exquisite subscription dankeschön huge
ja go finde ich tatsächlich nicht schlecht also ich finde ein paar sachen fragwürdig ja also
aber nicht so fragwürdig dass ich ich habe mir noch keine datei angelegt warum go sagt ich
habe für ein paar programmier sprache in allem voran c++ eine extra text datei wo ich mich immer
wo ich immer sachen die mir auf den sack gehen reinschreibe für den fall der fälle dass mich
irgendwann mal jemand fragt max warum findest du c++ immer so kacke so und go hat es bisher noch
nicht geschafft dass ich mir so eine datei angelegt habe das heißt ich kann gar nicht so
schlecht finden was ich in go gemacht habe bisher ich habe in go eigentlich nur eine sache bisher
gemacht das ist ein web cam überwachungskamera schrägstich web cam übersichtswebsite und der
teil was diese videos macht ist in go weil es die einzig sinnvolle library dafür in go gibt
deswegen habe ich damals mit go angefangen und die erste variante war eine mischung aus c und go
c weil ffmpeg und die ffmpeg bindings für go hardcore gesackt haben als ich es ausprobiert
habe so die ffmpeg variante war in c und übrigens das ist auch eine doch das ist auch ein punkt
der mich an go stört dass der interop mit c komplizierter ist als er sein müsste und auch
performance mäßig viel mehr performance braucht als es eigentlich sein müsste das war eine sache
die mich an go gestört hat also c interop war nicht schön die go philosophie ist schreibt
einfach alles in go das ohne miss das ist die offizielle go philosophie interop mit anderen
sprachen warum brauchen wir nicht einfach alles in go neu programmieren das das sagen die go
leute das ist natürlich massive big brain weil einfach mal jeder der ein bisschen video braucht
jetzt mal kurz ffmpeg neu programmiert ist klar ja allerdings man muss sagen go programmierer
sind immer besonders stolz darauf wenn ihre sachen in go programmiert sind es gibt so
viel software ihr müsst mal gucken auf auf self-hosted wo das angekündigt wird oder auch
auf auf auf github die einfach nur gemacht wird damit man dran schreiben kann written in go so
irgendwie dass das 150 programm was das gleiche macht wie alle 149 anderen programme auch aber
written in go dann ist das natürlich gleich viel besser nur weil das written in go ist bei
rust ist es übrigens genauso es gibt auch viele sachen die neu implementiert werden einfach weil
es geht und dann steht da written in rust von 10 minus minus gehört nein aber von holy see habe
ich schon mal was gehört ich weiß dass ich mir die viennese unleashed angucken wollte es gucken
uns klar hab ich das irgendwie wieder zugemacht ja und eine sache die mir auch noch in go auf
dem keks ging gucken wir uns gleich an ich bin ja bin ja echt mal gespannt drauf ich muss aber
das erst noch fertig fertig erzählen wo bin stehen geblieben genau eine sache die mir auch
noch in go ein bisschen auf dem keks geht ist dass die in manchen sachen unnötig minimalistisch
sind zum beispiel dass man sagt nein erase filtern mit irgendwelchen lambdas oder so ist böse mache
eine schleife natürlich kann ich eine schleife machen aber ich meine was ist was ist schöner
und angenehmer also wahrgenommen ich habe hier irgendwie den array 1 2 3 4 ist es erstmal vollkommen
egal was ist schöner ich kann sowas hier machen keine ahnung x größer 2 also was ist besser ich
kann sowas hier machen oder ich muss vor keine ahnung vor i in a i größer 2 dann oder sowas
machen was ist besser also mir gefällt das besser go sagt das ist besser die sind da manche ich
finde an manchen stellen sind bissel bissel zu minimalistisch obwohl sie eigentlich sich
das gar nicht auf die fahne geschrieben haben irgendwie super minimalistisch zu machen die
frage was ist performanter ganz ehrlich wenn das ordentlich gemacht ist braucht wahrscheinlich
beides genau das gleiche und selbst wenn das hier oder das hier ein paar tix schneller sind geht mir
das sonst wo vorbei weil die sache ist ja die schleife hat die sprache so und wenn man sowas
hier noch einbauen würde und das sollte wirklich irgendwie nanosekunden langsamer sein da kann ich
immer noch eine schleife schleife machen ja aber man kann es man kann es ja den programmierer
zumindest ein bisschen einfacher machen das war auch eine sache die mir an go auf den keks
gegangen ist ja und dass sie halt überhaupt keine generics wollten weil dieses dieses map
map konzept und sowas das ist in go irgendwie wirkt irgendwie auf aufgestülpt also aber es
kommt jetzt ja angeblich angeblich gibt es jetzt demnächst generics in go habe ich gelesen
weiß ich ob es es mittlerweile schon gibt gibt es ist das jetzt schon ist es jetzt schon live
oder ist das weißt du das jemand ist das schon draus oder kommt das irgendwie vor
future irgendwann future versions ach ja und was mich auch noch genervt hat in go jetzt wo ich
sie gerade wieder sehe sind teilweise sündags schichten zum beispiel dass es es gibt irgendwie
vier varianten oder so eine variable anzulegen teilweise exakt identisch und teilweise auch
feinheiten die sich unterscheiden ich weiß es sind c++ teilweise noch schlimmer aber c++ ist ja
auch keine messlatte ja gut so also so viel so viel dazu ja meine lieblingssprache bleibt so
und so sie scharf da kann man nichts machen also ich habe jetzt mittlerweile schon einige
sprachen ausprobiert und auch schon kleinere größere dinge drin gemacht aber wenn ich die
wenn ich die auswahl habe und es möglich ist was in dort net beziehungsweise sie scharf zu
machen da mache ich es immer in sie scharf aber wofür willst du generics wenn du compositions
hast zum beispiel dass man eine eigene dictionary implementierung programmieren kann eine ordentliche
type safe das geht ja so nicht wenn man sich wenn man sich die sachen anguckt die es gibt auf
github zusätzliche map und dictionary implementierung die sind alle nur sehr halbherzig weil es halt
keine generics gibt das ist der vorteil wenn man hauptsächlich von c++ kommt ja da schockt
ein nichts mehr das ist richtig so gucken wir uns mal die vernies unleashed ankündigung an mal
gucken was sie vor haben mit battlefield 3 es wäre ja mega poggers wenn battlefield 3 wieder
ordentlich spielbar wäre mit neuen surfern und allem aus die verwendest bettel sind battlefield
dem dings abmahnung von da ist es raus ich sag euch wie es ist wenn das eine einzunehmende
konkurrenz wird strikt da ist die in grün und boden das ist eine neue map ist das ist das
eine neue map oder ist es taller market das ist das sieht aus dass es das zwei das war das ich
wollte gerade sagen kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor ok man kann es das zwei in battlefield spielen
exquisite da läuft gerade ein live stream ok
orffatz ok scheine nicht so viele zu interessieren
wow
ach sind das developer tools von denen oder so was ja die haben eine neue map die haben
eine map editor guck mal die haben im battlefield 3 map editor gebastelt das ist schon nice oder
ist das ne das ist das ist immer noch das zwei hier mit den thorn und so zwischendurch würde
ich mal sagen also die thore sehen halt ultra das zwei mäßig aus die haben map editor in
battlefield 2 gebastelt der battlefield 3 das ist doch richtig gut das ist doch mega nice
ich meine ich will vielleicht in dem reveal treel stream was anderes zeigen weil das jetzt die
meisten heute nicht sonderlich interessiert aber das ist doch sehr nice da bin ich mal
echt gespannt drauf ok kommen wir uns mal den reveal den ankündigungs trelle an
sie haben das die haben sie haben in battlefield 7 gebastelt was ich nach was anhört nicht
dieses battlefield in battlefield 3 erinnert euch vielleicht noch was ist das zombie modus
oder wie oh habt ihr es gesehen das war das war ein neues squadmenü das ist ein 8er squad
10er squads oder ist es ein caster das könnte das ist in den caster übersicht oder sowas
was schaut ihr euch dann das ist der ankündigungs trailer zu venice unleashed das sind irgendwelche
leute die seit 2013 schon ich habe da schon vor ewigkeiten das projekt reingeguckt battlefield
3 wieder spielbar machen wollen ok so allzu viel hat man das nicht gesehen die hätten
sich irgendeinen dubstep trailer man von youtube suchen sollen die das für sie macht december
2020 exzellent es gibt ein ähnliches projekt für battlefield 4 ich habe aber vergessen
wie es heißt es gibt ein ähnliches projekt wie release unleashed was revamped ne oder
für battlefield 4 da weiß ich aber hier das da das da das da aber das ist glaube ich
das ist da er hat sich glaube ich noch gar nichts getan ich glaube da hat sich noch
gar nichts getan was play.com war das ja mal gespannt auf december 2020 endlich mal wieder
ordentliches battlefield spielen ich hoffe ja das taugt was und das schlägt ein bisschen
ein weil ansonsten geht es halt unter modding stream wann ich glaube daran beteilige ich
mir nicht wie moddet man das denn weder noch die haben glaube ich eigene level editor
und sowas gebaut deswegen hat es wahrscheinlich auch sieben jahre gedauert weil die viele
sachen selbst programmiert haben ja battlefield 5 ist zu unbeliebt dass das jemand macht vor
allem hätte da ist das mal gefälligst selbst machen sollen ja wir haben eine chance auf
ein gutes bf es wäre ja so geil wenn wenn das wirklich einschlägt also wenn das was
taugt den werde ich auf jeden fall auch dazu ein video machen einfach um die sachen bisschen
zu supporten es wäre schon cool es wäre nicht das erste spiel was quasi vom mod zum hit
wird irgendwie weil cs ist das bekannteste schlechthin wobei man halt sagen muss so ein
richtiger mod es ist ein mod aber es ist ja quasi also cs war halt ein half life mod
der was komplett anderes aus dem half life multiplayer gemacht hat aber venice unleashed
ist ja quasi battlefield 3 einfach nur in widerspielbar mit ein paar sachen dabei dota
genau gibt gibt ja gibt einige sachen und aber dota war auch hat mit dem warcraft 3
multiplayer was anderes gemacht als der warcraft 3 multiplayer war also es wäre nicht das erste
mal dass ein mod richtig einschlägt es wäre auf jeden fall ihn zu gönnen und es wäre
auf jeden fall geil wieder ein ordentliches battlefield zu spielen mit ordentlich vielen
spieler und allen dabei und wie gesagt wenn ich das erste mal dass ein mod groß groß
rauskommt ich hoffe dass das was wird aber ich ich wette mit euch wenn das groß wird
strike battlefield strike da ist beziehungsweise den laden in grund und boden also sollten
die wirklich also bei 5 600 spieler das juckt kein mensch ja ich rede auch nicht parallel
500 600 spieler 500 600 spieler parallel ist schon wieder was anderes wenn die mal angenommen
sollte man sollten die mal wirklich irgendwie sagen okay alter wir haben 10.000 spieler
oder sowas die die werden in grund und boden gestrickt das ist ja das wo sich nintendo
auch in letzter zeit so wahnsinnig beliebt macht das ist halt kacke also daran sieht
man ja auch wieder dass ihnen die community egal ist auch wenn sie das immer wieder sagen
die kommune die mögen also die community ist ihnen so lang nicht egal so lange die community
noch ihnen ordentlich geld gibt sollte das aber in irgendeiner art und weise sich als
konkurrenz erweisen zu zu battlefield was ihr geld bringt sind die schneller weg vom
fenster als die ihren webserver nach auf die bahamas umziehen können
nun gut chat das ging heute besser als gedacht also dass taugt gefällt mir welche in zukunft
verwenden wenn es an liest weiß ich nicht ob es taugt ob ich in zukunft verwenden werde
ich hoffe mal und jetzt sehe ich es 21.40 ich mache jetzt
ein stream aus wir sehen uns die tage ich gehe jetzt wahrscheinlich zähle putze dann
gehe ich ins bett irgendwie eine halbe stunde oder so also wir sehen uns leute bis denn macht
es gut bis zu den nächsten tage zu